Of course, hello everybody.
It is I, Crowkey, back at it again.
I am out of my cage for another Crow-themed game.
Sorry, sorry, I meant.
Oh my god, Crowkey, you just... sorry, Doki.
I got too immersed.
Doki, you just... you're recovering your voice.
Why are you fucking it up again?
I'm sorry.
I got too into the character, guys.
Whenever I'm Crowkey, I just... all I wanna do is...
That's all I wanna do.
You don't understand.
I can't help it.
Alright, before I play... what's it called?
Death's Door?
I thought it was a roguelite cause it looked... I've been trying to find some roguelites to play.
So like, it was either... I was gonna play this one or the other one which was like... what was it called?
It was something related to death.
There's an actual roguelite that's called Death's... what's it?
Oh my god, I can't remember.
It's the one...
cause I thought this one was the one that's about death that's like an actual roguelite.
And like, it was either that game or Death's Door.
But then I was like, I wanna... oh, is it Have a Nice Death?
Oh, I think it is.
Yeah, there's so many death-related games.
There's one where you try to do tax returns as death.
By the way, speaking of tax returns, I was registering at the Canada Revenue Agency today for like, tax reasons.
And I had to register a new account.
So I was doing that.
That was a fucking headache by the way.
That... I spent like a couple of hours trying to figure that shit out.
And... that sounds so exciting.
Oh my god, I love... I love being an adult.
Wow!
That is why today... today I... yeah, I finished it.
I fixed some problems and that required me to make a new tax account at the Canada Revenue Agency.
And it's okay now.
Everything is okay.
I had my staff members guide me on the step-by-step process because I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
So today, I don't feel...
I don't want to be a person anymore.
That's why I'm croaky.
Crows don't have to deal with taxes.
Crows don't have to worry about paying... getting tax returns.
Crows don't have to worry about social security numbers.
Oh my god, thank god.
Crows can live a free life.
I'm about to tax my crows.
Anyway, so crows can just steal...
Exactly, exactly.
Why pay taxes when I can steal gold?
That's the life, being a crow.
Anyway, before we play the game, I'm going to show real quick.
If you guys didn't know, there is an official croaky plush that is out now.
Right now.
Wow, you can buy me right now.
So you can own your very own croaky plushie.
If you order at youtubes.com slash collection slash jokeybird and you can grab your own croaky plushie.
That's right, me.
That's me, guys.
Wow.
Alright, chill complete.
I bought it already.
Yeah, but did you buy just one?
Why buy one when you can have two?
Why buy two when you can have three?
Why buy three when you can have four?
The possibilities are endless.
Exactly.
The croaky has spoken.
I don't remember what all my expressions were.
Oh, there's me putting my hands down because I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
I have one where I'm just tired.
Let me rotate myself down a little.
I don't want to look a little too freaky.
Alright, so this is apparently a soulslike.
I didn't realize it was a soulslike until I guess I read the game description and then I was like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
This is not a roguelike.
It looked like a soulslike.
It looked like Hades and I was like, oh, have a nice death as a roguelike.
I was like, oh man, I really want to play a roguelike today.
That's what I want to do today.
And then so, so, so I thought that was a roguelike.
And then like today I checked it before I made my waiting room today.
I checked it and it says soulslike.
I was like, no, no.
Wait, what do you mean?
Um, so yeah, I guess, I guess that's what we're playing today.
I guess that's okay.
I'm trying to rotate myself.
I'm going to be on this side.
Ooh, maybe I want to look like it.
Ooh, hey guys.
Give me a sec.
Whoa, I'm trying to roll.
I'm practicing my rolls for, for the game.
Ooh, there's me front facing croaky will never hurt you.
All right, let's see.
I guess I'll face this direction.
I guess that's the best one, right?
Is it?
I can't tell.
Okay, here you go.
Yeah, I'll be here.
All right, there you go.
No, actually, no, maybe I like myself being here.
What if I just don't look at you guys?
What if I just stop looking at you guys?
Let me adjust myself, guys.
Being croaky is hard work.
It ain't much, but it's hard.
It's hard work.
It's honest work, guys.
All right, now I'm here.
Okay, let me move myself here.
All right, there you go.
Wow, okay, there you go.
There you go.
Much better.
That much better?
Yeah, much better.
Ooh, maybe I'll... Okay, there you go.
Much better.
Yeah!
But nothing changed.
You're just facing... You just wrote... You just flipped yourself.
It looks much better, guys.
You don't understand.
It looks much better.
You don't get it, okay?
You just don't get it.
You just... You just don't understand, chat.
You just don't understand.
Okay, I don't know what my default... Should the default be here?
Yeah, my default should be here.
Is my default here best?
I don't know.
I don't know if I should like... Do I face here for my default, guys?
Hmm, I guess I... You know what?
Yeah, that's fine.
I'll rotate a little bit.
I'm sorry.
I'm being a little picky right now with how I'm... Okay, there we go.
There you go.
That should be fine.
I'm trying to get my... I'm trying to get my good angles, guys.
I gotta look good, chat.
Alright?
It's been a while.
Krooky's gotta look good.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kami Kuroshi, I can text.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Every super chat gets a... Void Time, thank you for the super chat.
Sorry, I'm trying not to make it too... I'm trying not to illustrate it.
Try Stone Start or Eden for some roguelites.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Not a roguelite?
Congratulations, you're playing yourself.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's boot up.
Let's boot up the game.
Alright.
Guys, is this my good angle?
Guys, is this my good angle, guys?
Do you think I look great, guys?
Do you think I look good?
Is this my good side, guys?
I need to know.
Is this my good side?
Best angle?
Is it?
Okay, alright, I believe you guys.
As long as you think I look good, that's all I care about.
Let me rotate here.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Alright, I look great now.
Okay.
Alright, I'm ready.
Sorry, I gotta make sure I look great.
I look handsome.
I need to look like a handsome crow.
Five big caws from me.
Thank you, Mehdi, for the super chat.
Thank you.
Caw.
Audio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Caw.
Alright.
Okay, I think that's my... I think I look good now.
Okay, I have to make sure that we got all the right angles.
Alright.
Guys, okay, I'm gonna use mouse and keyboard.
I know it says maybe I'll be better in controller, but if this is a souls-like... Wait, actually, I don't know.
I feel like I react better on M and K because I played Hate.
I feel like I do, but I'm not sure.
I'm not sure, guys.
I'm using wings, so I'm not sure.
I don't know if I should use... I'm not sure if I should use... Oh my gosh.
Okay, let me know if... Okay, keyboard and mouse.
V, left attack, middle mouse button, chart.
Okay, let's get a controller.
Oh wait, you guys can't see the game.
I'm sorry.
I realized I forgot the one thing.
I have to show my video game first.
Alright.
Sorry, croquis new at this.
Sorry, guys.
Croquis is new.
Instinct and try controller first.
I feel like... I don't know.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's better with controller or M and K.
But like, we'll try controller first.
Maybe the world will be nice to me today.
Maybe it'll be nice to me.
I don't know.
Alright.
Do I have to reset?
Okay.
Oh, do I have to... Okay.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I have no idea.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, she turned into a roller player.
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you.
Alright, let's start.
There's me.
That's me right there.
Do you see me?
I'm down there.
Right there.
Sorry, I don't... My hands don't work today.
I'm tired.
Alright.
Now arriving at Reaping Commission Headquarters.
End of the line!
Oh, there's me.
Okay.
Oh, I have a sword.
Oh my god.
Oh, and I can roll.
See, that's what I was doing earlier.
I was rolling.
Guys, nothing else.
Ain't got no souls.
Ain't got no shinies.
Ain't got no worries.
That's me!
I told you!
When you're a crow, you don't have to pay taxes.
No worries.
No money.
No worries, guys.
Just like that.
He knows what's up.
That's me right there on the streets.
On the fucking streets.
Yeah, you're clear.
Moving along, bud.
Yay!
Wait.
Wait, but where's my sword?
Oh, he doesn't give a fuck.
Alright.
Okay.
Hall of Doors.
Hello.
Better get moving.
Don't wanna be late, right?
Where do I go?
There's two ways.
Where do I jump?
Okay, I can't go that way.
Okay.
Also, let me know if the sound's okay, sound guy.
Ooh, the music's nice already, though.
Well, well, well.
Oh, Shandler.
Look who showed up for work.
No worms for you.
Because only the early bird catches... never mind.
Anyway, it's your lucky day.
I actually have a soul for you to reap.
And not just any soul.
A giant soul.
Think of the commission on that.
I hope you haven't forgotten your training.
Stay on your talons.
Giant souls don't often go peacefully.
Dropping in your door for you now.
Wait, they're putting me in?
Into the action?
Whoa!
That's a door.
With a soul that size, you might be able to afford some time off.
But remember...
Oh my god, it's like Fire Bay.
Your door will remain open until you return with your designated soul.
While your door is open, you will be mortal and you will age.
So get it done quickly.
Reaping souls to power the doors just so you can reap more souls.
And the cycle repeats forever and ever.
You're here forever, little guy.
The rat race, eh?
Anyway, get to it and be careful.
I love capitalism.
Wait, I thought...
Being a crow means I get to escape that!
Wait a minute!
Wait!
Wait a...
No!
I can't ever leave capitalism!
Crowplism...
No!
Not even crows can escape the grind.
Oh boy, I love typing.
Can't get enough of it.
I thought I could leave the grind.
No!
Alright, let's see.
Oh, where's the door?
It's like right here, right?
Oh yeah, it is.
There's death's door.
Sad co... co...
Guess it's time to be a mortal.
Whoa, colors!
The great grove of spirits.
Okay.
Alright, here's me.
That's me rolling.
Whoa!
Oh look, there's a little guy.
Hello, little guy.
Oh.
You're so scared, little guy.
Why are you following me?
Okay, I can open... Oh, I can open these doors.
Okay.
See, little guy.
Try to kill little guy.
Nothing personal, kid.
That's fucking right, get out of here.
Oh, wait, I have a bow?
Oh!
Oh, that's cute!
Oh, I have a bow.
It's like a gun.
Wait, I used up all my ammo.
Wait, no!
I didn't know I'm living around...
No!
Demonic force... I didn't know!
Oh, I do not like the flashy though.
Oh, I wonder if there's a way to turn...
Okay, I need to know if there's a way to turn that off.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like how flashy that is.
Okay.
Oh, Emily flash is nice.
Nice.
That's good.
That flashing isn't... Yeah, that... Okay, I'm gonna turn it minimums too.
We do not care about that.
There we go.
Oh my god, that's a lot better.
That's actually... That... Oh shit!
I'm sorry.
Alright.
Wait, I have... I can bow.
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, you don't like that.
I also don't like screen shakes too, so...
I wonder if this works.
Oh, it does.
What?
What's he gonna do?
Slam on me?
Oh shit, no, he's not doing that.
Wait.
Can I break your leg?
Go down.
Leg go down.
There we go.
That's right.
Get down from there.
First boss completed.
Never challenge Croaky!
I've seen things.
Whoa.
What?
Oh, maybe... Okay, maybe he can challenge Croaky.
Hello, little guys.
Are these the dragoons?
Get out of here.
Let's go home.
Boo!
Turkey, please.
Why would she do this?
Guys, personal space, guys.
What?
Croaky the man 6 feet.
Guys.
Personal space.
Where am I?
What the fuck?
Is this a dungeon?
Oh, hey, look.
What'd I get?
I got lightspeed.
Oh, which can consume the rooster.
Oh, I get to have my HP back.
Don't you?
No space between us.
Guys, 6 feet, guys.
Have you forgotten about your protocols?
Alright, let's see.
I guess we go this way.
Oh.
I actually turn it up?
Okay, there we go.
Oops, there we go.
That should be better now.
Alright.
Oh, hey there, guy.
He seems like a bad man.
Just cause he's...
Just cause he has no head.
No head equals bad.
So, that was years.
That was like 4 years ago.
Guys, I'm a little worried that you forgot that COVID was actually 4 years ago.
That was not a long time ago, chat.
That was...
Yeah.
That worries me a little bit.
Oh yeah, sorry.
5 years ago.
Can I activate this?
Oh shit, nice.
I wanna go this way.
Oh, there's another thing here.
It's retro hours.
Alright, I guess I go back?
I go home now?
Hello, I'm home.
A little crow.
That's me!
Do I sense a lot of solar energy?
Come here, and you can trade in those souls to gain an edge in combat.
Okay.
Yippee!
I did my job.
I'm...
Clocking in and clocking out.
I love crowpolism.
Welcome to the soul vault.
Would you like to increase your combat abilities?
Okay, build attack with speed and precision.
Okay, guys.
I wanna know who are the 5 people that played this game.
There's a nice way to ask for that croquis.
Thank you for the super chat, Lord Crow.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Do I put it all in strength?
Who are the 5 other crows that played this?
Show yourself.
Do we just be...
Do we just put it all in strength?
Oh, we can't.
We're broke.
Nevermind.
Guys, nevermind.
We're broke.
We can't spend money yet.
Hello, did I do it?
Is that a good oh no or a bad oh no?
You've lost your son, so I killed him!
Check the VOD!
That's the one thing we didn't want to happen.
Well, get back out there.
Don't come back until you find...
What?
But I killed him!
Check my VODs!
Check my camera!
Check the camera they installed on all birds!
The government installed it on all of us!
Check that camera!
Okay.
Where do I go?
Do I go to the cemetery or the grove?
Okay, where is my camera?
Where do I go?
Guess I go up?
Instructions unclear.
Oh, it is like a souls-like.
We're like, I don't know where to go.
That sounds right.
Just like all my souls-like adventures.
Where the fuck do I go?
What?
Oh, there's no fall damage.
Thank God.
Don't be broke.
Mom, thank you for the magenta super!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll kill him then.
Get out of here.
Only I can fly here.
I'm a crow, but yeah, I can fly.
My hands are too busy holding this cool-ass sword, I guess.
Whoa.
Whoa!
No hands!
Stop!
No grabbing!
Stranger danger!
Alright.
Nice.
Personal space, bro.
That's what you want.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
We got him out.
Get out of here.
Woo!
Arrows does jack shit to them, though.
These guys can not- These guys are like one hit.
Okay.
And then I'll pick up the key.
Whoa!
Oh, does it- Oh, no.
It's just like- It just means I picked it up.
I don't need heals.
I'm invincible.
Title card.
And where else do I go?
Where else is there a key?
This way to the summit.
Okay.
Oh, there's a key.
Alright.
Oh, yeah!
What is this like?
This is like- So, it's because they respawn when I leave.
Okay.
And when I go home, I get my HP back.
Oh, shit.
Whoa!
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, fuck!
I'm sorry.
I was not paying attention.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, it's not over yet?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Get out.
Okay, these guys are like one-shot, so I don't have to care too much about them.
Okay.
Okay, I think like he- I can't hit him when he's like just a face.
Oh, shit.
Whoa!
Okay, let me get closer to this guy.
Come on!
Get over here!
That's right.
Fucking stupid.
Come on!
Yeah!
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
There's more?
Oh, shit.
Now there's a face man and him.
Oh, my God.
Stranger Danger Man is here too.
Stranger Danger Man.
Get out.
There we go.
I can't kill him before.
All right, get over here.
Oh, shit!
That's right.
Your number one enemy.
Walls.
Yay!
What a dumb guy.
I know, right?
Can't even beat a crow.
I'm like that crow with a knife.
There used to be a crow in Canada that would terrorize people.
And like he found- there was a stabbing or something.
And then like the crow picked up the murder- well, it wasn't an attempted murder weapon.
The crow picked up the- the knife.
The crow picked up the weapon from the scene of the crime and then went around flying around with a knife.
He's the infamous knife crow.
That's my crow sheet right there.
Not just any crow, crow key.
Crow gang.
No, that's my- that's my crow- that's my crow sheet right there.
Oh, hey.
Hello?
A reaper!
My time in this world is over.
That's right, get over here.
I need a soul right now.
Unfortunately, I'm still alive.
Please, I need to pay off my debts.
Please.
I have a family.
As in, a family of one.
Sorry, maybe try hitting me with a heart attack.
Don't worry, I got you.
Phew.
I only have one attack.
Oh, I have two attacks.
Let's go.
No.
He's still here and still very much alive.
Perhaps try a bit of a run up?
I can run attack?
Oh.
I'm sorry, it's not your fault.
It happens to- guys, I'm- it's my first- guys, I swear, this is the first time this happened.
I've killed many other people.
I swear to God.
Guys.
I'm afraid I'm burdened with unending life.
I can't explain it and I spent untold years seeking an answer.
My name is Steadhone.
I'm the keeper of grades on the sacred mountain.
Oh, and if you do find yourself stranded somehow, feel free to try and kill me again.
Okay.
I swear to God, this is like the first time it happened.
I've killed many other people.
I swear to God.
This is only the first time, guys.
I've killed so many others.
And they all- they all died and left me glowing reviews.
What's this?
Here lies the guarding of the door, a preserver of order and a home to stray souls.
They all- yeah, they all died satisfied.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God!
Thank you for it.
It's so small.
Alright.
Croaky the Grim Weaker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Simple.
Thank you.
God!
This only- this happened once, okay?
It's the first time it's ever happened, guys.
You saw me kill.
You guys saw it.
Yeah!
Climb up.
Sure, we did.
We definitely- are the dead people that you definitely killed here in the room with us right now.
No, they're not because they're fucking dead.
Because I do a good job.
Okay.
I don't know when I'll ever use this attack.
I feel like- you know what I love about this game?
There's no parry button.
Thank God.
For now.
From what I've seen yet now, there is no hidden secret lies within.
What?
What's the secret?
Oh, it has a twin.
So this- For now.
Oh, yeah.
For now, I don't have to worry.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay.
I guess we don't go here.
I'll go this side.
First.
Pew!
Oh, shit.
Nice.
One shot.
Okay.
That's good.
At least now I can two-shot.
Ah!
I don't know how a dog can fly!
I'm a crow!
Why can't I fucking- This is for a crow family.
I- I thought there'd be an invisible wall!
How the fuck was that supposed to be an invisible wall?
Oh, part two.
Where the fuck- I guess I need to plant a pot.
Where are the pots in this game?
Yes, where the fuck are the pots?
Oh, no.
I don't know where the pots are.
Have I been here?
Why are they dead?
I don't remember here.
I clearly killed somebody here.
Was that a shortcut?
There's a pot right there.
Oh, I have killed here.
Okay, I'm gonna go- Oh my god, it is a soul slayer.
I have killed.
Guys, all the killings are blurred together.
Croaky has- Has no recollection of all these kills.
Okay.
Yay!
Om nom nom.
Om nom nom nom.
Alright, back at it again.
Oscar, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Gah!
Okay.
Let's just roll faster.
Alright, up I go.
Croaky climb.
Croaky keeps climbing.
Guys, I'm not gonna remember where I am very soon.
Okay, what if I wanna take an elevator?
Secret!
I knew it.
What's the secret over here?
What?
Oh no, it's over here.
Secret?
I'm praying?
Does Croaky have a god too?
Woah!
The ancient shrine offers you a shard from a vitality crystal.
Collecting four will raise your vitality beyond- Yay!
Health up.
Okay, I need to find four more.
Okay, so I got more HP then.
Crow god.
I prayed to my crow god and he granted me vitality.
Now I can last for it.
Now I can actually kill.
Okay, so that is not with my charge attack.
That means I have to come back here.
Oh shit.
Does he know where to- Okay, he can roll up then.
Alright, nice.
Is there a secret here?
Wait!
Okay, so I can knock them back with the bow.
Okay, good to know.
Stupid.
That's actually really good to know.
Okay.
Alright, get over here.
So fucking stupid.
That's okay, right?
Give me your fucking plan too.
I'm mugging you.
Welcome back to London.
I don't know where to go.
Do I have a map?
No, right?
Cause it's like, so it's like- Okay, thank god.
I'm trying to be like, how far is this- Do I survive all fall damage?
Do I know map?
I feel like you can make up some stuff cause I feel like not a lot of people have played or streamed this game.
So you guys can say anything and I would like not even know if it's true or not.
I'd be like, whoops.
I'd be like, I just believe you.
Probably, should we test it?
Alright, let's see.
Oh shit.
Magic.
What you going doing with magic, huh?
Loser.
Fight me like a true man.
Like a true crow.
That's fucking right.
These guys are like babies.
They're so weak.
Oh fuck!
Okay, I regret saying that.
Why?
I didn't think he'd do that, okay.
Okay.
Oh shit, I think he's gonna use a spell, yeah.
There we go.
I gotta be careful of this guy.
Oh fuck, what?
Holy shit!
They actually fight back, guys!
I was not expecting that!
Okay, thank God.
Plant the seed.
Okay, thank God there's a seed planter.
I was gonna be like, extra fucked if there wasn't.
How dare these children fight back!
Okay, I got two.
Out of that.
Let's get a third in.
Okay.
Oh shit.
That was unintentional.
No, no, no!
What the fuck?!
Oh my God!
And there's so many!
What the fuck do I do?!
Oh my God, wait, that's so fucked up!
No, I can't get enough!
One use only?!
Okay, that's messed up.
They actually surrounded me.
That's actually so messed up.
Oh my God, thank God.
That's crazy.
Like, I couldn't, I can't even leave!
They actually...
Okay, now I know...
Don't go in the corner.
If Croaky goes in the corner, it's bye-bye.
Oh my God.
They all like, surrounded me.
That's fucking crazy.
And okay, now I know that the plants are one use.
Oh my God.
I couldn't even get out of it!
Or like, invinci...
Like, dodge it.
Like, invincible frame it.
Or use like, what is it called?
Invulnerability frame?
Or I-frame it?
I couldn't even do that.
They literally like, fucking surrounded me.
Guys, there's no pots.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
That does not look like a good castle.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys.
I don't think this castle...
This does not look like a...
A nice castle.
Guys, I think this castle wants to kill me!
Okay, I deserve at least like...
Like, some fucking form of HP or something.
Like, this is not fair.
Woah!
That's right, get arrowed.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, I can't...
I can't charge my attack.
Oh my God.
I actually can't charge my attack.
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
It's okay, I'm faster than the laser.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Okay.
I just...
I go in and poke them and then I...
Oh, okay.
I think he's gonna do the laser attack again.
Right?
Yeah.
It's fine, I'm faster than the laser.
I think.
I go in a circle.
I loop-de-loop.
That's right, get loop-de-loop.
Oh!
Oh shit!
That's...
Oh no!
He stomped on me!
Ah!
Oh my God!
He fucking...
Oh my God, it's not fair!
Wait, do I have enough for upgrades?
Oh, I do.
Alright, guys.
What is the optimal upgrade?
I can't believe it!
He fucking stomped on me!
Oh!
Alright, damage first.
Alright.
Strength first.
Yeah.
Okay.
We do strength first.
He sat down on me.
And then I died.
It didn't help that I went in with 1 HP.
At least it resets the health pots, right?
I hope it does.
I'm just gonna run through everything.
Just like...
Just like my Souls game.
Except for him.
Fuck that one guy.
And that guy too.
Fuck those two guys.
They don't deserve to live.
I think it's this way?
I'll just run through everything.
Okay.
I don't think it's worth, uh...
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Wait, they can fly up here?
That's fucked!
There we go.
Okay.
Alright, give me a sec.
Boom, boom.
Okay.
I got an extra bow shot now.
Woah!
And I got 3 shot.
Oh, fuck!
What the fuck?!
Okay, I'm just...
I was too greedy.
I admit.
And then a loop-de-loop.
Weeeee!
I got a little too greedy there.
I cannot do, like, a charge attack on this guy.
He fucking...
He, like...
He moves too fast for...
Oh, shit!
Like, I can only hit him, like, once.
Or twice, maybe.
If I'm lucky.
If it's nice to me.
Okay, and then he does the laser too.
Weeeee!
You're so stupid!
Yeah, that's right!
I'm talking about you!
You're so stupid!
That's fucking right!
That's why you have no eyes!
Oh, you're right.
I could do the roll attack.
That's smart.
Okay, is he gonna do the thing again?
Watch this.
Weeeee!
Woah!
Okay.
Nice.
I'm just gonna do the roll attack then.
That's right.
Okay.
Nice.
That should be, like, stronger too.
Woah!
I rolled into him.
Accidentally.
I got a strong attack in.
Alright, do it!
Do the thing!
That's right!
What am I gonna do?
Oh, shit!
There's two!
Oh, no!
Okay.
I did not expect that.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I can't do roll attacks anymore.
He attacks too fast for me.
Oh!
He attacks way too fast now.
Okay.
It's okay.
I still do it.
Oh, I can't just loop the loop anymore.
Oh, he won't let me!
He's too mad about the...
Guys, he's too mad about the loop the loop!
Woah!
There we go.
Okay.
Is he getting closer?
Oh, nice!
Goodbye, Casa.
Fenrir, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, Toki!
Oh, thank you for your very first Akasupa!
That's right!
Get down!
This is Kroki's house now.
Your very first Akasupa or Super Chat in general!
Gah!
Jake, it's my birthday, but I won't be able to watch it live.
So, can you wish me a happy birthday?
Of course, I can!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Fenrir!
Gah!
Happy birthday, man!
I almost...
I almost like...
I would have to admit...
I did almost fucking...
Walked off the bridge.
It was that close.
Thank you for this Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Pal, thank you for the Super Chat!
Wait, where am I going?
This way to the summit.
Oh, I'm still going to the summit.
Oh, is that a battle or a siege?
Thank you for the Super Chat, Pal!
Thank you, thank you!
Gah!
Where do I go?
This way?
Okay.
I've been enjoying it so far.
It's fun.
I like...
I like the...
I really...
I like the mechanics of this game so far.
It's not too complicated.
And the dodging system's fun.
I'm sad there's no iFrames though.
It doesn't seem like there's iFrames, but I can't tell.
I feel like if the...
I don't know.
I don't know if it has iFrames.
There is?
Oh, there is?
Okay.
That's good to know.
Where does this go?
I can't reach it.
I'm...
I can't fly.
A crow that can't climb.
Fly.
I can climb.
I only have one skill and that's just stabby stabby.
Oh, but it's really tight?
Why doesn't your...
Why doesn't...
Because I broke my arms!
Is that why you are here?
They clipped my wings!
They clipped it!
Now all I do is stab.
Oh, hello fledgling.
Or maybe I'm just a child.
They gave a child a knife.
It's not about the crack on his head, but I needed that soul.
You see, I was a Reaper.
Just like you.
Just like me?
Years ago, my Simon invaded capture.
It took many minutes to track it down to this location.
Upon arrival, I discovered that it somehow passed through this door.
Inconceivable.
Do you know where we are, fledgling?
No?
Where are we?
That's a big ass door.
Wait!
Full Metal Alchemist?
Oh, it's Death's door!
Guys, I finished the tutorial!
Guys, I did it!
It only took me one hour.
The end point for all life.
I thought it was just a legend.
Oh, he should be older.
As you know, all doors are powered by energy of souls.
Perhaps with a true monumental amount of power, even this one could be forced open.
Sadly, the soul I stole from you was not enough.
Sir, they're gonna fire me if I don't bring back that soul.
Sir!
I'm afraid that our fates are very much intertwined now, fledgling.
Will you ride me?
For if your assignment isn't complete, your death is not...
Wait, what?
What?
Without the soul that now resides behind this door, you are trapped.
Just like me.
Wait, what?
Why are you doing this?
I was just a random crow you picked out on the street!
However, fortune may still smile upon us.
That's fucked up.
He pointed at a random crow and he's like, you're next.
This cursed land is hidden to the reapers, somehow untouched by the laws of nature.
The creatures here have the potential to live vastly beyond their years, growing ever larger and more powerful.
Now I'm gonna become old!
Just like you!
Now!
I know of three such beings on these isles, whose combined soul energy could grant us the power to wedge this door open.
To the north lives an old witch, obsessed with escaping the clutches of death.
Beyond the forest to the east, a self-proclaimed king rules over the ruins of the flooded cathedral.
And atop the mountain to the west, a beast of untold years, primal and vicious, with no want or desire.
No!
I'm truly sorry to have entangled you, fledgling.
But my vance here, my body grows weary.
It's your fault!
I'm gonna be old!
Your path is your own now.
Either venture into the wilds and reap those giant souls, or choose inaction and suffer fate as this old fool.
Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
This is your fault.
Do you wish for guidance on where to head next?
Okay.
Okay, north.
Which way is north?
I don't have a map.
That doesn't help me, sir.
I just need to find another crow.
Clocking in their nine to five and put them through the same hell he put me in.
That's it.
That's all I have to do, guys.
As long as I find the other crow.
The never-ending cycle, it follows.
I'm gonna it follow it.
Alright.
Hello?
Oh, this is like a dungeon, right?
A witch's dungeon.
I'll go this way.
Whoa, soul?
Yippee, soul.
Bad man?
Okay, they look like they could come alive.
They're just standing there like they're gonna fucking come up alive and kill me.
They do not look like props.
Okay, I need to go here.
I like how I'm like prancing.
Like a crow.
Because he is a crow.
No way.
Wow.
I can't believe this lamp has legs.
I wonder why they gave this lamp legs, guys.
I wonder why.
There we go.
I like that roll attack.
Roll attack's cool.
Like, roll attack's pretty neato.
Okay, nice.
What do I do here?
Is this an elevator?
Oh, it is!
Ah, that's cute!
That's a birdcage elevator.
That's cute.
I've never played Hollow Knight, but does this game feel similar to Hollow Knight?
Oh, I can break boxes.
Nope.
Okay.
How many plants do I have?
Two.
Oh, very different.
Is there anything in those boxes or am I just an asshole?
Ha, silly Doki.
All crows are assholes.
Okay.
Nice.
There's nothing here.
There's still nothing here.
Where the fuck does this witch live?
Burn your weapons and spread joy?
I don't... I don't think I'll do that.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Oh, I can do the other stuff!
Wait, that's so smart!
Wait!
You!
I'm so smart.
I like that.
That's a cute mechanic.
That's right.
Of course I'm smart.
I'm a crow.
Crows are one of the smartest birds out there.
Second to like... are they like parrots or cockatiels?
That's why they live longer.
That's why caring for like a cockatiel is like caring for a child that never grows up.
That's why it's like people who own like big birds like power to you.
Cause they're very annoying.
I think like... I think like ravens are the smartest, right?
There's like a specific type of crow or raven that like is like one of the smartest birds out there.
I wanna say crows are the smartest.
I think a raven is.
Hello there, my... like a specific type of raven.
My beak-faced fellow.
Oh my god!
Is this... Is this the crow's world of the... of the bucket head guy?
Magpies.
Am I thinking about magpies?
Yeah!
This is like the crow version of the pothead guy.
It's quite unusual to see one of your kind upon these isles.
I imagine you must be here for a soul.
Not me, I should hope.
Anyway, it seems our paths have intersected in an opportune unmoved moment.
You may not have noticed, but I have been cursed with an unusual affliction.
Alas, judge me not by the shape of my head, but by the deliciousness of the soup inside.
Pothead.
Wait, his name is actually Pothead!
Where are my manners?
I'm very pleased to make your acquaintance, beak-faced.
The literal Pothead.
It would seem that my journey has reached an impasse.
I haven't been able to overcome the obstacles ahead and lock the iron gates.
If you would help me move on, I should be indebted to you and we could push forward together.
Stabby stabby.
Alright, I have to help him move some stuff.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I don't have enough souls.
350.
No, I don't have enough for upgrade.
Not so dead, Pua.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just wait for it.
God, just wait for it.
For Silksong to play Hollow Knight.
Alright, surely I'll get it in 10 years, right?
Oh shit, wait, he has a bow?
That's not fair.
Oh shit, how did I miss that?
Does this go through?
Okay, no it doesn't.
That's good to know.
Okay.
Guys, look.
Death perception is really hard.
Okay.
Oh my god, I can't.
I just suddenly forgot how to play the game.
Okay, I like that.
I don't know how, but I just suddenly forgot how to play this game after that one fight.
Oh fuck, that's illegal!
What the fu- Okay, I'm not doing anything fancy no more.
I'm just gonna X.
No more fancy shit from me.
I try to be a little fancy and use my charge attack, but never again.
Okay.
Unless- Okay, that worked though.
That worked though, guys.
That worked, so it's fine.
That worked, so I can do it.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, yippee!
Okay, up I go.
Okay, let's- I'm still like 1 HP.
I'm not gonna plant yet.
I still have like 1 extra.
Wait, but how do I do this?
I'm scared.
What is this?
Okay, okay, I had to be sure, okay?
I gotta- I was like- I was- I almost- I almost tried to hit it with my sword.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, this bitch.
What the fuck?!
How did that not hit?!
Okay, now it hits.
Jesus.
I'm so bad at that!
I- I don't know why I'm so bad at that!
The roll right click.
Okay, no.
That was just a shortcut.
Did I do it?
Did I do the thing that he wanted me to do?
There's so many shortcuts!
Where am I?!
Where the fuck am I?!
Okay, I'm here.
Okay, I got one of them.
I'm just- I'm confused.
There's too many places to go.
Oh, there's another HP.
Nice.
Maybe there's like hidden stuff places too around this area.
Is there that vitality- Like look, there's like a thing here.
See that?
How do I get there?
Why is there a staircase?
Yeah, look!
See?
How do I- How do I get there?
Let me in!
I know there's a way to get there.
Oh my god, there's another one!
How the fuck?
Just fly.
That's- That's fucked up.
That's fly, sis.
Not all crows can fly, guys.
I can't believe- That is so insensitive, guys.
That is so insensitive.
Fly, you fool.
I could report you right now.
Alright, I went left side right, so...
Yeah, ableist.
That's ableist.
That's fucked up.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I got the right click in.
Alright, let's get over here.
You know what?
Fuck you.
Yeah, that's right.
You think you're better at being a bozeman than me?
Get out of here.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Yes!
Look at that.
I'm a gamer.
Okay, I knew I could kill him before.
Oh shit, what if he fucking kills me there?
Oh fuck.
Wait, okay.
I got him.
Nice.
Oh, it's like a little trap.
The guardian of peace.
Don't worry.
I'll come in peace, guys.
Oh shit.
What if I just...
Oh nice.
Oh, I could've killed him right there!
Oh, I wish I did.
That would've been so cool.
Not gonna lie, that would've been so cool if I did that.
Jesus, fuck you.
Yeah.
I know you can't get me there.
Jesus, get back here!
There we go.
Yeah, that's right.
Get your ass back here.
Okay, this should be a shortcut.
Um, I don't know if I should waste my heals.
I won't.
Actually, fuck, okay.
I'll get the shortcut here.
And then...
Okay, if I get hit here, I'll use my heals.
But I don't think I will.
Because I'm a gamer.
I feel like it was gonna be a self-fulfilling prophecy right there.
I thought I was gonna get hit.
Oh shit.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Nice, got it.
No.
No!
It auto-locks!
It's not fair!
Oh, thank God that doesn't hit me.
It auto-locked!
Okay, I feel like there might be a boss fight out there.
The Guardian of Peace is fucking collapsed.
I'm gonna get a heal.
Just cause, like, the Guardian of Peace does not look so good.
There's like a portal somewhere here.
Look, there's another portal.
How the fuck do I get there?
Without flying!
Om nom nom nom.
Heal time!
Okay.
I'll go this way.
Roll time.
Roll, roll, roll.
Just fly.
Fly in the bushes.
Are you stupid?
Hurrah!
We can now venture onward, my steadfast companion.
But first, we should grant ourselves a moment of respect.
Come, sit with me for a while.
Oh my God, would he have healed me?
Oh my God, I'm so cute.
As I mentioned upon our meeting, I was not always quite so earthenware in appearance.
A strange curse was visited upon me by the wicked old lady who resides in the mansion beyond these lavish gardens.
I imagine you're here for her, are you not?
Surely her soul must be swollen and ripe for the reaping due to her unnaturally extended years.
I desire not but to confront the old witch and request she undo her ceramic deed and restore me to my former handsome self.
I was quite the looker, you know.
Really?
Soup?
Sure.
I'll eat your- wait, no.
Come on, I'm hungry.
So be it.
Let us push once more.
Isn't that like part of his brain?
If I'd eat your soup, would you lose more brain cells?
I'm here asking important questions.
I like this.
Oh, fuck!
It was green!
I was like, friendly?
How was I supposed to know?
It was green!
Green for HP!
Yeah!
Green for HP, guys.
It broke the fundamental rule.
I can't believe it.
It broke the number one rule.
Green for HP.
Wait, then like, what the fuck was the point of that?
Oh, this has to be short.
This has to be a secret.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Green like the...
Like the nitro boxes.
Exactly!
We've all done it once.
Don't lie.
You've all done it once.
Why was there a maze here?
Oh, I don't like this area.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I don't like this area at all.
No!
Okay, okay, we gotta run.
We gotta run.
But I need to break this guy first.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I need HP.
I blame green.
I blame that one guy that I thought was...
That I thought was like an actual healer.
Where did he go?
Okay.
Oh, I missed.
I can't wait for like the other weapons.
To see how the gameplay changes.
Let's see.
Oh, there's so many places to go.
Croaky's overwhelmed.
Croaky's so overwhelmed.
Where do I go?
You mean it's not linear?
Oh, no.
Croaky's worst enemy.
When it's not linear.
Maybe if I can...
No, follow him.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, my God.
I hate that it's not...
That it doesn't follow him.
Maria, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gah!
Hey, Doki.
I just finished work and it's my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday, please?
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Maria.
Gah!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
Oh, that looks like a boss fight right there.
That looks like a juicy one.
Okay, let me go over here real fast.
Alright, here we go.
Hello, sir.
Friendly?
Why do I even ask that?
We all know you're not friendly.
Jesus Christ.
Wait.
Wait, he's blind.
Wait, he's stupid.
Okay.
Oh, he's plus 50.
Yeah, no fucking wonder.
He's blind.
Bro, I get more from picking these up.
This is a plus 100.
He was a plus 50.
Very friendly.
Yeah, he was definitely friendly.
The garden of life.
Ooh.
Okay.
Where'd I go?
Is there a fire here?
No.
How do I light this?
Oh, I don't think I need to light it up anyway.
Oh.
Oh, these guys.
I don't have to worry too much about them.
That was a plus one.
I think there has to be something over here.
Because it's just like... nothing.
Hello?
Friendly?
Oh shit.
Oh, these guys.
Oh fuck!
No!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, I appreciate that though.
At least they're hurting themselves.
Okay.
Oh, they can hit themselves here too!
That's good to know.
Oh, there's way too many enemies now.
Oh.
They like increase the difficulty of the game by just putting more enemies.
Oh, I don't like that.
It's like harder to deal with.
When it starts getting too cluttered.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
If I can like...
Like, how do I...
I think I have to have a special ability.
To cross the water?
Yeah.
I'm not even supposed to be here.
Dude, I have like this anchor thing so...
Oh no, I have to backtrack.
No!
I gotta backtrack later.
When I gain my special ability.
Or, you know, fly.
That's fucked up.
That's insensitive, guys.
Poki's a ground bird today.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Oh, oh, fuck!
Oh my god, I...
No!
Oh, there's too many...
There's too many things!
Oh my god.
That's right.
Krooky had an accident.
Makes you feel like shit, don't ya?
Oh my god, what do you mean there's more?
No, I fucking walked into the arrow!
The accident of 1987.
Oh my god, I actually ran into the arrow.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
It's okay, I can run through everything.
I don't remember how I got there though.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Where am I?
I don't remember.
There's...
Why did I run through everything?
Am I stupid?
Where am I?
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, guys, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't want to run...
Okay, I'm resetting.
I'm resetting this.
I'm resetting.
Alright, where am I?
Still...
I still don't know where I am.
Okay, we go down here.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
Hello, sir.
I need an upgrade.
I want to get...
Can I get HP?
Guys, what do I get?
What would be better?
I don't know what to get.
Rupert's speed and grace of movement.
Rupert giving this...
I feel like...
Do I need...
Speed would be good.
Okay, I'll do speed.
Meep, thank you for 10 gifted shivs.
Thank you.
Ha!
Okay, I'm a little faster now.
That's right, chase this.
That's right, you can't chase this when I'm fast as fuck.
Boy.
I do not...
I cannot tell if I'm faster.
I cannot tell at all.
Also, don't...
Oh, there he is.
Why didn't you help me?
You said you'd get my rear.
Where the fuck was...
What...
Where?
Where was it?
Okay, it was like this way.
I wonder if I have to fight that big boy again.
Is he still alive?
No, he's dead dead.
Well, thank god at least he doesn't come alive.
Okay, it was this way.
And he lied to me.
He was like, don't worry, pal.
I'll save you.
I'll make sure you have backup.
And I'm like, backup where?
Where backup?
I hear sparkles behind me.
What the fuck is sparkling?
Guess I'll never know.
Alright, this way.
How did I...
Oh, here I...
Jesus, how I died.
I remember now.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Alright, we got one down.
There we go.
Other one down too.
Oh, oh, don't...
Don't...
Oh, fuck!
I keep running into them by accident.
Okay, thank god he...
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
I'm glad that he like ran in there by himself.
That's really helpful.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of these guys first.
Okay, nice.
Come on, show up.
That's right, you think...
You think being up there is gonna save you?
Get closer.
That's fucking right.
Get your ass over here.
I'm loaded up.
There we go.
Oh, I can smack the spells?
Oh, wait.
That's good to know.
Wait, is that another weapon?
These blades can...
Oh, I got a new weapon!
Damage 0.86...
Oh, wait.
It's not even...
Oh, it's faster.
Oh, it's a lot faster.
Alright, let's try this out.
Dagger time.
I thought I was gonna throw the dagger, not gonna lie.
I should be able to sit on that chair.
Okay, let's go.
I will make a good statue, would I not?
What did you do?
So here we are.
Okay,
goodbye.
I need to unlock this area first, guys.
Okay.
Shit!
Oh my god, there's the arrow.
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
God damn it, I'm taking everything to the face right now.
I'm taking it all to the face.
Okay, I need to heal.
No, it's fine.
I'll be okay.
It's okay, guys.
Everything will be okay.
Wait, what?
Is this a puzzle?
What the fuck?
It doesn't even tell me how to beat this puzzle.
Fucking nerd.
It's like, give me an answer.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Read?
It says a family tomb.
What do you mean, read?
There's one piece of dialogue.
Apparently not.
Apparently, I don't know where the fuck that meant.
Fucking read.
Read doesn't help.
Oh, there he is.
Oh no, it just says the garden of love.
Fucking read.
Read my ass.
Anything here?
I'm gonna die here, aren't I?
This feels like a death area.
Why is it so empty?
I don't like the emptiness.
I feel like there's something that's supposed to be here.
Alright, let's cover him now.
Sorry, I was a little distracted.
If you go ahead, I'll guard the door.
Wow, thank you.
Thank you so much.
What?
Oh.
Okay, let me get HP real fast.
Don't worry.
I'll be right back.
Real helpful.
Oh shit.
Oh, I forgot about these guys.
Oh fuck no, he fucking poofs in.
It's okay.
He can't catch me.
He can't catch me if I just run a little faster.
Oh, did they regrow?
Cause I went through the door?
The fuck's my HP then?
It's okay, I'll go the long haul.
Oh, they did!
That's okay.
Now I went this way.
That's not okay.
Don't worry.
I'll dodge it all.
Don't worry guys.
I'm just not even gonna- I rather just like- If they're gonna come back, I'm just gonna go back to the door.
And heal from there.
Wherever my door is- Oh my god, imagine if I got hit there.
Placebo!
Thank you for the five gifted shits!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, but like, it wastes an item.
To use the- Think again.
It wastes an item and I don't wanna waste my seed.
Just for like, HP that's next to the door.
It's just more convenient that way.
Wait, does- Oh, the plant regrows?
Wait, what?
It does?
Wait, the plant regrows?
So I don't have to worry about it?
I didn't know!
Okay, now I know.
Okay, now I know though.
Guys, I learned.
What the fuck?
Creak.
Oh wait, there's a door.
I forgot to open the door.
Open the keyhole!
To my heart.
Just like Kingdom Hearts.
Wait, they're all potheads.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Is pothead the real witch?
I hunger for souls.
Wait a minute.
Oh, they have heads for pots.
Or pots for heads.
Look at them all.
Wait a minute.
Is pothead not a good person?
Okay, I'll plant this now.
Where do I go?
This way.
This unassuming chair right there.
Maybe I can kill all the pots.
Oh shit!
Oh, it was a joke!
Nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's evil pots too.
I didn't think that would actually happen.
Oh my god!
No, not the children.
Not the children.
Oh, I can hit them back!
Thank god.
Okay, thank god.
I was a little nervous about that.
I'm glad.
I don't know which is better.
The knife or the...
Or the dagger.
Does anyone know which is better?
The knife or the dagger.
Okay.
That's right!
Be gone, child!
Dagger because it's cool.
True.
Good answer.
What?
Just to be sure there's no evil.
Dagger doesn't stagger?
Wait, are these staggering?
I didn't even notice.
Can I do it?
Oh.
I have to do the other side too.
Oh yeah.
Oh!
Do I have to curve it?
Do I have to curve the shot?
Oh no, I can just do that.
Nice.
Curve the...
Curve the arrow.
That's right, child.
Oh look, they're all having a little dinner party!
Look at that!
Making sure there's no evil jars.
Not paranoid at all.
Get out of here, child.
Is there any secret here?
Any secret?
That's right.
I'm gonna crash your party!
Okay, nice.
Oh wait, there's one more.
Oh!
It's right here!
Wait, how do I get there?
Wait, what?
I can't jump!
How do I get up there?
Can I roll?
Oh fuck!
Oh, oh, oh!
That's when you...
That's when I have a Eureka moment.
That's three O's.
Can I get three O's in chat?
It's like the boom guy.
It's that boom I go.
Oh!
There you go.
There's a bad jar here somewhere.
I can feel it.
Wait, what?
What?
What is this puzzle?
Oh!
I figured it out, guys.
It's this way.
Uh...
Oops.
Simple geometry.
Right there.
Um...
Oh fuck.
Oh, give me a sec.
I need a think.
Alright.
We're mathing right now.
And then we do it here.
I assume there is one over here.
Simple geometry.
And then...
Here.
Oh my god.
Easiest puzzle of my life.
Get out of here.
That's right.
You're seeing the wrinkles on my brain get wrinklier and wrinklier.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
The fuck?
Oh, am I target practicing this?
Oh!
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
Wait, what?
How do I kill you?
Am I...
Am I killing it?
No.
Oh, I am.
I am.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
I couldn't tell.
Alright.
That's right.
Get over here.
Get that child over here.
That's right.
Oh shit.
Spit that child out.
Send it back to where it came from.
Oh fuck.
What?
That shouldn't have hit me.
Oh my god.
There's so many...
Drago's birthday.
Happy birthday everybody.
Wait.
Why is today a very special day for births?
Guys, minus nine months for me, guys.
What month is it?
You decided to use the bathroom.
Alright, bro.
I wish you a happy birthday before I go to the bathroom.
Happy birthday to you.
Alright.
Sydney, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh shit.
Oh, that your parents were so...
It was a special...
There's a special...
There's some special days in July.
Or June.
Oh, you're right.
Summer vacation.
Happy birthday Sydney.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Sydney.
Yeah.
Thank you for playing.
Of course.
It's a croquis game.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I am...
Because there were so many birthdays today.
Usually, I do like one or two.
But I think I like wish like five birthdays today.
That means...
Minus nine months.
There was something special.
There was something special nine months ago.
I'll be right back.
Bathroom time.
Bathroom break for croquis.
Alright, I'm back guys.
Evan, Mike, Matty, Rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let me...
Wow.
Let me double check something real quick.
Before croquis goes back in.
Alright.
Here we go.
Climb up.
Johnny, parpa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so dead, pa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you...
What the fuck?
For the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello?
It appears we've been abandoned here.
I don't think anyone is coming to open the door.
Give me your soul.
Croquis demands your soul.
Four of them?!
Oh my god, there's four lost souls in here?!
Wait, how do I get out?
Do I have to walk back?
That's fucked.
What the fuck?
I have to walk back?!
Croquis mad.
Caw dollars.
Thank you for the super chat, Coyote.
Thank you, thank you.
Caw.
What the fuck?
Wait a minute.
Who are you?
Wait, is that the witch?
It looks like the Ghibli witch.
The deal is off?
What brings an adorable fellow like you into my little house?
Deal.
I just laughed there.
Sorry, ma'am.
Sorry.
I just laughed.
It's just like, what the fuck?
She was trying to have a conversation with me.
Oh yeah, I don't have to.
Thank God.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize she was so slappable.
How do I get out of here?
I slapped her and I don't know where to go.
A tabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Caw.
Chat, I'm so hungry.
Oh, nice.
What do I eat for dinner?
Pizza or burger?
I'm hungry.
I might eat this crow on screen.
You should...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, it's exploding, guys.
You should get...
Pizza.
Pizza is always good.
I'm gonna grab heals real quick.
Okay, I grew it there.
I'm just gonna get max HP.
Oh, what?
Hello.
Alright, let's...
Heal yourself.
Oh, she's right.
Why not both of you are so hungry?
Aren't you so hungry?
Oh, there's a lot of...
Get out of here.
That's right, child.
Leave.
Okay, there's that.
Oh, wait.
There's another one right here.
Thought I didn't see, huh?
And then there's...
Extra money.
Money?
Poki like money.
Where else is there?
Oh, there's a seed right here.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Apparently, something.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Spin?
Okay.
Bye.
Okay, this guy I'm a little afraid of.
Just cause like...
He actually explodes.
Oh, he doesn't.
Oh, it's the purple one that explodes.
I'm a little special.
Poki confused.
Look, even though crows are very intelligent...
Oh, shit.
Did that hit me?
That is bullshit.
Are you serious?
That hit me?
Okay, like I was saying.
Although crows are very...
Very intelligent.
They are just as intelligent as like a four year old.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Someone can fact check me.
They're like...
They're like as intelligent as a toddler.
So like, I'm...
Doesn't really account for much.
If you think about it.
Oh, seven year old.
Yeah.
So like, it's not really that much of an improvement.
Ah, fuck.
No, my death field.
No.
What the fuck?
There we go.
What's over here?
Fuck this pot.
Oh, I guess I can't fuck this pot.
Oh, I can do that.
Okay.
How do I get up there?
Oh, I locked it.
Okay.
Again.
Can't believe it.
I rolled off the same area too.
This way.
I have to go this way.
I'm liking this game so far.
I feel like if I wasn't streaming it, I definitely...
I definitely would play this off stream.
As like a...
Like...
Just like to chill.
It's pretty fun so far.
I'm enjoying it a lot.
Wait, there's two of you?
Wait, that's not fair.
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, this is actually not fair.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
That's bullshit.
That's bullshit!
What?
Okay.
That's fucked.
Where am I?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I was like, where do I go?
That's actually bullshit.
I shouldn't have died there.
Nevermind.
Take it all back.
Jesus.
Stupid.
Remember where...
Oh, it's this way.
Oh my god.
This is the worst part about having no map.
I'm so disoriented.
I'm so confused.
When I have no map...
I'm confused.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
What are you guys doing here?
Get out.
God damn it.
Fucker.
I can't.
Oh my god.
These guys are so annoying.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fuckers!
Oh my god, that's okay.
That's fucking right.
Are you serious?!
It traveled that far?!
Get out of here.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I don't like that.
I don't like that they spawn non-stop until I kill the big guy.
I hate non-stop enemy spawners.
No thanks.
Power up my door, soul.
You're just here to be...
You're just here as a battery for me.
Alright.
Jesus, that's a lot of dead bodies.
Oh, there she is.
Hello.
What the fuck?
Leave!
That's right.
How could you make your house such a mess?
Slap!
What are you still doing here?
Huh?
Leave!
Wait, is there not a shortcut back home?
I thought there'd be a shortcut.
She gave me a shortcut last time.
I guess cause it's like next door.
Croaky is so rude.
How's there more of you guys?
I'm not your mom!
Get out of here!
You're so rude.
Alright, next key.
Oh my god!
Why did I do that?
I didn't know!
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm not doing so well in this level, guys.
This level fucked me up.
There were too many pots.
Okay, oh this guy.
Wait, not him?
This guy?
Oh, what the fuck?
He was just standing there.
Oh, he was naked!
He was naked!
So he got scared.
He's like, no, I'm naked now.
No!
He has no pots to cover him up.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Just wanted to re...
Just get my skill back up.
Jacob, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Gah!
Anybody remember the dream key crow show?
What is that?
I actually don't know what that is.
What is this?
Oh, I picked up more seeds.
I need a pot to grow this.
Get out of here.
Yeah, I don't trust...
I don't trust all these random pots just sitting there.
Okay, wrong one.
They're just sitting there.
Threateningly.
Okay, we'll go here first.
Oh hey, it's a little bathtub.
What?
What do I do here?
Oh!
It was an invisible key!
Wait, on the other side, there's like a thing here.
Yeah!
It's like there's another one right here.
There you go.
Oh, that's cool!
Secret!
I shall pray to my crow gods.
Hello.
I am here for vitality.
There was a guy that made fun of me saying that...
That...
Saying I couldn't kill him.
Yay!
Okay, I need three more.
That's clever.
Okay, one here.
Oh, I'm hearing voices, guys.
Do you guys hear it or am I crazy?
Oh shit.
Guys, do you hear the voices?
Are y'all hearing the whispers?
Okay, nice.
Guys, Croaky didn't take...
Oh my god, Croaky's not going there.
Yeah, Croaky's gonna go this way first.
This way seems more safe.
Whoa, this way definitely does not seem more safe.
This place looks like a fucking boss battle.
Oh, this is a shortcut!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Not safe.
Croaky needs to heal.
No!
Why have you not replenished this for Croaky?
Why?
Get out of here!
Can't believe it.
I'm like 1 HP.
I need like...
Anything right now.
Please slap this.
Where are my heals, child?
Children, where are my heals?
Get out of here!
I don't remember where the other heals were.
I like, planted so many seeds.
But like, where were the heals for all of them?
There's like one up here, right?
Yeah, there is.
Okay, I'm just gonna go up there then.
Let's grab that one.
Okay.
Oh my god, the long travel.
Nice.
I got my seed insurance.
Sorry, there were too many children.
Croaky doesn't remember.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, now I can fight the boss.
Wait, there's another seed here.
I'm just leaving them here.
Alright, Croaky's coming over.
I'm coming over.
What?
Oh.
Shall we dance?
Okay.
Wait,
what?
Wait, what?
Will he get tired?
Okay, I learned that I cannot arrow this guy.
Okay.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Wait, no, I can.
I just can't stop the- I just can't stop it.
I can't CC it like the other ones.
Oh, he's naked.
Get out of here.
He's naked now and he's scared.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, his pot's too strong.
Where am I now?
Get rid of this child.
And then this child.
I want the money here though.
I need the money.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh, my money.
Bro, what?
Like, oh fucking hell.
Give me a sec.
Okay, give me a sec.
I was trying to- I was trying to figure out where I was.
Okay, this is not fair.
Oh, he was there?
That is definitely not fair.
Stupid man.
Okay, I have to cut it.
Oh, okay.
I'll grab that later.
Is there anything?
No.
I feel like there has to be a secret here.
Why else would it lead me all the way here?
Oh my god, seed.
Is that it?
Was that all it was for?
Is there no secret?
Oh no, here it is.
What did I get?
Now I just have to find someone who would want to marry me?
What the fuck?
Wait, what did I get?
What did I get?
Oh, it's just like a collector's, right?
Like an achievement.
It's just a collectible, right?
Alright, let's grab this.
Up we go.
Koki, go up.
Goddammit, so it was useless.
I wasted all those arrows for nothing.
Oh, I don't like this.
Can't see anything.
Oh, I cannot see anything.
Oh, they're not one-shot anymore.
Because I'm not using my sword.
Oh, I like that.
I like that they're not one-shot.
I might swap my weapon to deal with these guys.
Yeah.
Oh, fucking hell.
Just to make sure there's nothing here.
Okay.
So I can one-shot them.
Whoa, hey guys.
Get out.
That's right.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, he just stopped.
He was like, my friend!
That's right, I killed your friend.
Alright.
I'm gonna use the sword.
I think the sword's better.
I finally realized that.
I think the sword is better.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh, there's the other crow.
Why did the door close?
How can we get back?
Goodbye.
Now power up my door.
That's your only purpose left.
Life doesn't matter now.
Okay, we're missing one more.
Alright, we're gonna meet the old granny again.
Oh, goodness.
You're not the cause of all this wreckage, are you?
No, I'm just a crow.
Oh.
Oh, she's not happy.
I would not be very hospitable to any beast who would mistreat my children.
Tread lightly, reaper.
Bitch.
Alright, let's go this way.
I don't think she likes me, guys.
Oh, look, there's a... I can't go that way.
There's a trap door here, but I didn't...
I didn't check what that was over to the right side.
Slap.
I didn't check what this was.
This has to be something, right?
Oops, missed.
Oops, I missed again.
Oops.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
There you go.
There we go.
I did it.
It only took me several tries.
There you go.
Oh yeah, no, this...
Yeah, no, this sword is definitely a lot better.
I don't know what the fuck I was doing.
Oh no, why did I plant my seed there?
Unless it's a boss... Oh, it's a boss, but never mind.
Fuck!
Oh my god, and there's these guys too?
Sucks.
This actually sucks.
Oh my god, and there's these guys as well.
I hate it here.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I'm using this against you.
Oh, fuck you!
I hate it.
I hate the infinites.
I hate the infinites so much.
I hate it.
I hate that it spawns.
I think that's the one thing I don't like about it.
I don't like that it spawns infinite.
If it was like a set spawn, it's fine, but it's not set at all.
Damn stupid magic user.
Fight me like a real crow.
Okay.
I have to kill all of them before more spawn in too.
Because I'm pretty sure if I don't, more will spawn in.
God, you fucking whore!
You're such a whore!
Okay.
Wait, does it actually not spawn more?
Maybe it doesn't.
Okay, I'm just gonna... I don't think it does actually.
I know it actually doesn't spawn more.
Thank God.
Oh, shit.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
It doesn't spawn more.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
It doesn't spawn more.
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Wait, there's another one.
Oh, they were all there.
I'm starting to question the authority of our Lord of Doors.
Although it might be a bit late, given that I am deceased.
The Lord of Doors?
I thought it was just a witch.
There's more?
God, I can't wait for more heals soon.
I need more heals.
Our children.
Thank you.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, do you think she'll notice?
Oh.
That's true.
I knew it!
I knew they were related!
I was like, why are there so many pots?
Like, heads as pots.
In the portraits.
It's the one there.
It's the grandson.
Filling that head of his with nonsense ideas about curses.
And then you come in here and smash up all my beautiful urns?
I'm just trying to help people.
If you set foot in my basement, there will be consequences.
I might even have words with your employer.
Oh my God, she's gonna go to my manager!
Oh my God!
No!
Not my manager!
I'd rather not see that old weirdo again.
I mean, a lock for the head?
So strange.
Off with you, little crow!
Still slapping you, though.
Still gonna slap.
Alright, nice.
Oh no, she's a Karen.
She's a Karen all along!
What the fuck?
I was like, where is he running to?
This way.
Down I go.
Alright.
Hello, grandson!
Hello, son!
Wait,
where's your family?
Where's your dad?
And your mom?
You see, all...
She was stricken with grief when my grandfather passed and made it her whole mission to keep her whole family alive forever.
Her research led her to believe that replacing one head with an urn would somehow strike you from death's ledger.
However, I resisted, and during the struggle, her spell must have gone away.
As far as you can see, I have a pot for a head.
I fear that she has gone too far beyond her years, and her soul has swollen and grown corrupted.
I've seen it happen in this land many times.
As a reaper, I implore you to end her suffering and bring her soul into the next life.
Oh my god, he's asking me to kill her grandmother!
Oh no!
I'm gonna slap her.
Perhaps she can find peace once again.
He gave me permission to slap her, guys.
It's okay.
I got permission.
Be wary, living reaper.
But I ain't afraid of no ghost.
Let's slap her to the afterlife.
What the fuck?
I'm back home.
Wait, I don't think this is home, guys.
Nevermind, I am not back.
Oh wait, now I am.
See?
Wait, I don't think so.
Nevermind.
Alright.
Time to open the chest.
Wow.
Wow!
Oh, it's a mimic.
Aware race.
What does that mean?
Oh shit.
I don't like that.
Oh shit, I don't like that.
Nice.
Okay.
There we go.
I'll use these against you.
That's right, send more in!
Send- Oh fuck!
Wait, but like in an evenly fashion though.
There we go.
Send them in in an evenly fashion!
Oh fuck, okay.
Oh fuck!
I did it twice!
Sorry.
I got a little- I got a little confused for some reason.
I don't know why.
Okay.
Where did he go?
There you go.
Where are they?
Oh shit, there they are.
Do I just blow them up?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Nice.
I'm gonna use them against each other.
Oh, I missed, but that's okay.
Okay.
No, not him.
Not him.
Okay.
I'm just gonna get rid of the smaller guys though.
Okay,
we try again.
They swung around and around!
Okay.
Okay, I know how to fight this now.
I know.
I'm gonna start gaming guys, don't worry.
But right now.
Starting now.
Starting now, guys.
Okay.
Alright, okay, okay.
Starting now.
Starting now, guys.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, guys, stop.
Okay, where's the...
Okay, nice.
Where did this guy come from?
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, no!
I got too cocky.
I got too cocky!
I'm getting too cocky!
No!
I keep getting too cocky, guys.
Maybe they won't keep spawning.
Maybe.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
I can use this against them.
Oh, they don't keep spawning!
That's good!
Wait, that's good!
That's all I ever wanted!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Okay, we did it!
Alright, I know they don't keep spawning, okay.
I beat, like, every other time they kept spawning!
As I'm supposed to know!
It stops now?!
Oh my God, King Crow?!
Crow God!
A gift to a fellow crow to aid you on your quest.
Oh my God, Crow God, you're real?!
I knew I wasn't praying to something!
Nothing?!
Praise be to Crow God!
Yippee!
That's a big-ass crown for a tiny crow.
Oh, I get flame spell?
Wait, what?
Oh, I don't have enough XP for that.
No XP.
Crow Jesus!
Bye bye!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, Dark Birdy!
Okay, now...
Oh my God!
I'm unstoppable!
Gimme go!
Wait, can I...
Go there, then?
Maybe I can roll over there?
I'm so smart!
But how do I get out?
Now what do I do?
Wait, how do I get out?
Oh, there's under the stairs!
Oh, there is!
Wait, I made it harder for myself!
Because I'm so smart!
Quite strange, but it's above my pay grade.
I find it's better not to ask questions.
Oh, one of the High Commissioner crows got bribed!
They got bribed by the witch!
They closed it down!
Someone's taking bribes now!
Okay, we need to find a pot to farm our fucking heals.
I just realized that I should've been farming my spells.
There's a conspiracy out there.
Release the documents.
Release the witch files!
Okay, I need to farm this.
Alright, there we go.
A crow-spiracy!
I'm here to crack the case!
Oh my god.
Call me, call me.
Hello, crow.
I see you've been exploring the old office departments.
I used to work over in the East section.
Before I embraced my true life and quit the rat race, I'm much happier now.
But that was one lovely, cozy office.
Get out of here.
What are you doing?
Are you cheating on me, dragon?
The fuck is this?
What are you doing?
Get out of here!
Yeah!
Oh my god, he's so cool.
Seems like you're finding a wealth of souls out there.
Where are they coming from?
I haven't seen so much soul energy in decades, maybe centuries.
Wait, what?
Ceramic Manor?
Oh!
Oh, I'm back here!
Wait, what the fuck?
I'm back here.
I guess I can upgrade.
Yeah.
Alright guys, what do we want?
Guys.
What do we want, chat?
Wait, that's cheating?
Yeah!
I planted the seed!
You still belong to me!
Alright, we'll get dexterity.
Okay, we should be going here.
Oh, we're back here.
Wait, what?
Another one.
Remember who planted the seed.
I found it.
I found the seeds.
I don't know where they came from, but I planted it.
Oh, there.
Okay.
This unlocks the basement.
There we go.
This must be where I killed the witch.
That's right!
I have custody!
Alright, that must be to get my skillset back.
Okay, down I go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's how it works.
Gotta pick up more seeds.
Where are we?
Is this...
For an old witch, the fuck was she doing?
What was she fucking doing up down here?
What the fuck?
Why is upstairs no go nowhere?
Where does upstairs take me?
Wait, that was like useless.
There was nothing up here.
Okay, there's clearly something over here.
I'm gonna put this cart all the way back here.
Wait, no.
I can't.
There's nothing here.
I have to get another car.
This is so different from like Crustate.
Crustate like looked nothing like what I'm fucking experiencing right now.
Like this is like a new area.
How do I open this though?
Yeah, it doesn't go through the gate.
Oh, it's right here.
I see it.
I didn't see the hole right here.
Okay.
There you go.
And it opens this.
And it opens that here.
Sorry.
My bad.
Oh my god.
I'm like trying to do a drive-by for this stupid urn.
Ah!
I'm trying.
I swear to god, I'm trying.
I don't understand!
Like, it goes too far.
I can use a dagger?
Oh, the dagger does less.
Oh my god, you guys are so smart.
It doesn't work.
It still... it goes the same.
It goes the same.
Oh my god, it's so hard to time it.
Oh my god, this is actually so difficult to time.
Jesus.
Okay, we did it.
That was so difficult to time.
Oh my god.
Oh, what was it for?
This better give me 200.
It gave me 100.
That was all for 100 souls.
Okay.
Where am I?
Hello?
Is there any secret here?
Secret?
No secret.
I don't know if I'm going, like, main quest line or side quest line anymore.
There's so many things here.
Like, I can't tell.
I'm so lost.
Are we main quest line or side quest line?
Where am I?
Is this main?
No, like the pathway I went to.
Cause I didn't go a different pathway.
I went through so many different areas.
Oh, there's another seed.
Oh, I am?
Oh, that means the other way was the side.
Cause I went a different- there was another way too.
Wait, there's a shrine.
I wanna pray.
Let me pray.
How do I pray to you?
Wait, I wanna pray to the crow gods.
Oh, there's their son.
Hello.
I warned you, crow.
Yet still you persevere.
I'm not quite sure if that's admirable or stupid.
No, it's definitely stupid.
Now if you'll excuse me, I must have some alone time with some infuriating young lad here.
Hopefully, I can make him see sense.
Now please, go away.
Woo, disappear.
Alright.
Kamehameha.
Alright, open the door.
Now this granny's techy as hell.
Oh fuck, she built an undergrad factory down here.
I did not expect that.
Now I'm in the furnace?
Where the fuck am I?
I'm gonna reset my HP.
The fuck?
Oh my god, where am I?
I'm gonna grab some kamihas real quick.
Oh, fire.
Fire.
Okay.
What?
Oh.
Oh my god!
Now it's- What are you- What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
What are you?
At least it travels through, that's good too.
Okay.
Now it's steampunk?
I'm so confused.
We're steampunking, I guess?
From potheads to steampunk?
Alright.
Get out of here.
I know you can't do shit when you can't spin.
What can you do when you can't spin?
Oh my god!
Oh fuck, guys, I don't think I can dodge that.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Shit.
I got confused, guys.
I got confused.
My bad.
Okay.
Oh fuck!
Oh my god!
Give me a sec!
A lot of things are going on, I gotta plant my seed!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
Okay, nice, I got him.
Alright.
I'm gonna take this real fast.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your- Oh fuck!
Wait, you can fight back?
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, now he's dead.
For real.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Kamehameha!
Oh.
Let me through.
Okay.
I don't know how the little blob's gonna try and kill me though.
No!
Okay.
That's my bad.
I got a little too cocky there.
I wanted to do the extra little damage.
That was not worth it at all.
Oh.
Go up.
Seed time!
I'm running out of seeds though.
Guys, I'm getting tired.
I'm actually tired.
I'm like the Mr. Fantastic meme right now, guys.
Too many.
Wait, how do I...
I wonder...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Secret!
Yeah!
That's right.
You aren't taking custody!
My children now!
Okay.
Oh, here.
Yeah, this way.
Have I been...
Oh yeah, I've been here.
Okay, just resetting that.
Oh my god, he's big!
Big boy!
Okay, and then they become little mini boys.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I need to not get greedy.
Sometimes I get way too greedy.
I can't help it.
I just want to slap them.
Oh, the little guys can do it too!
They just don't live long enough to do it.
Okay, now I know that.
Okay, I'm just gonna kill you.
So you don't make more.
Alright.
Over here I go.
Oh no.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god he's special.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Do I need secrets?
No secret.
Oh shit.
Okay, that was a little too close.
Pew!
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
You use arrows against fire?
You are stupid.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, I got...
Oh, thank god.
I didn't get stuck there.
Oh, I was worried I was gonna get stuck.
Okay.
Oh.
So many blobs.
Okay.
Nice.
Jesus.
I'm trying not to be...
Guys, look!
I'm not being greedy, guys!
I'm actually basing myself!
No more green!
I do learn!
Alright.
I learn.
Okay.
Roll.
Oh, look at these little bi- Oh, shit.
He's a big boy.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
No!
See?
There's so many things on my screen!
I wasn't greedy!
I was- It's just smoke!
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
There's literally just smoke!
Okay.
I'm not gonna be greedy.
Don't be greedy, Doki.
Don't be greedy!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I wasn't greedy.
Alright.
Big guy becomes small guy.
Are you serious?
Okay.
That's bullshit.
That- Okay.
Okay, you gotta admit.
That one was- That one was bullshit.
That one- That one was bullshit.
There's no way.
Jellyfish!
Thank you for the- Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
That shouldn't have killed me.
That should not have killed me right there.
Okay.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck you.
Oh, my god.
I'm coming over.
I'm fucking coming over.
I'm gonna slap you.
I'm coming over.
Ah, shit!
You stupid arrow!
Taking custody of this child, too.
Guys, I should not have taken- I should have left that child alone.
I should have- Okay.
Okay, that was my bad.
I will admit.
That was absolutely my bad.
I should not have done that.
Now I know.
No!
I'm being greedy!
Child had body.
Oh, my god.
I'm being greedy now.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, that guy just ran off.
I - Lord Kuro says, Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
Tomorrow is John Mita's birthday.
Can we get an early happy- Of course!
Happy- God!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear John.
Okay, poor little guy.
He really wanted me to dead.
I'm gonna put it on strength next.
The moment I get enough.
Fuck this.
Oh, my god!
I hate how there's- The iframes is like- It's so hard to do the iframes in this game.
This one is difficult for iframes, I feel like.
Okay.
I think it's definitely a lot harder.
Oh, my god.
Kamehameha you.
What hit me?!
You!
I went into the poison.
I hate that enemy so much!
It CC's me.
That's a deadpull.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank- There's so many birthdays I told you guys!
Something happened nine months ago.
There must have been a big party.
That's a deadpull.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Adoki.
I've just been informed it's John's birthday.
Can you get a happy birthday, please?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear John!
Sorry.
Happy birthday- I'm fucking- I'm just gonna die.
Just end this.
Actually, no.
I don't want to see the defeat side.
I'm just gonna reset.
A birthday to you!
No!
Okay.
Let me...
Let me reset this run.
Wait, do I have enough?
I have enough.
I'm fucking buying strength.
Fuck this shit.
I'm gonna beat up some fucking goos.
Me mad.
Me going- Me strong.
Me be big, strong bird.
Alright.
I'm a strong bird now.
I could run through it.
Wait, can I?
Let's try.
I run through.
I'm gonna run through.
Oh my god, I forgot I unlocked this area.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid.
It's so sad.
I'm just gonna kill these guys though.
These guys are very annoying.
These guys are very fucking annoying.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I just want to kill him.
For all the suffering he's giving me.
And then you get the fire.
You get the fucking fire.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
We just ran past.
Oh my god, we fucking did it.
Oh my god.
I should've been running in the first place.
I don't know why.
I just got really cocky.
For some reason.
Wish I could kill him before he starts rolling, right?
Yeah.
Oh, I just...
No!
My shield!
That's fucking right.
See you, dad.
Okay, goodbye.
Nice try.
Oh, shit!
Where did he come from?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I got custody of my children again.
Alright.
Get over here.
Okay.
Oh, does it like keep spitting?
If I just...
Oh!
I see.
So like...
He keeps spitting.
I don't know.
Cause I didn't...
I just killed his jar for him.
Wait, I feel like there's something down here.
Guys, there's nothing down there.
It was glowing!
Guys, it was glowing.
Okay.
It was glowing.
I thought there would be something.
Okay.
It glowed.
It glowed, so I assumed there was something.
Okay, nice.
I got him out of the way.
I'm just gonna kill him before he shoots that arrow.
Alright, we made it there.
We made it here wherever we are.
Where are we?
Wait, this might be a secret!
Maybe I can light it here.
Wait, why did it let me go here?
It's not a secret, guys.
Fucking lied to me.
What is it doing?
Oh, shit!
Fucker.
Oh, my god.
Fuck, okay.
Oh, fuck!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, I don't...
No!
Shortcut!
Purpose!
Guys, I did that on purpose!
Guys!
Guys, I did that on purpose, guys.
So I can...
Guys, it was a...
It was a shortcut.
It was a skip.
Guys.
Okay, there you go.
Just as planned.
Tactical skip, guys.
Oh, my god.
I hate this fucker so much.
Tactical skip, guys.
Tactical skip.
I would've wasted time if I didn't do that.
What the fuck is he doing?
Okay.
Oh, child.
What the fuck were you doing, bro?
Okay, let's see if there's anything there.
Hello, Mexican!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
God!
By the way, I have a friend named HelmetIsTrash.
And it's his birthday today.
Can you wish him a...
Okay.
For some reason, I feel like...
One of you guys are lying about a birthday.
I don't know.
I feel like some of you guys might be lying about birthdays now.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to...
Oh, fucking hell.
I didn't even see you.
Happy...
To...
Sorry.
Helmet.
Happy birthday to you.
God!
Okay,
there we go.
Alright, I'm gonna reset and grab my HP.
James!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey, Doki.
Tomorrow is my buddy John's birthday.
Can you wish him an early birthday, too?
Of course I can!
If he's real or not, I'll never know!
God!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear John!
God!
Happy birthday!
Okay, C-Tab.
Okay.
I'm just gonna kill them just for the sake of...
Just for the sake of, like, an extra...
I mean, it's like plus one.
It's actually not that much.
I feel like it's not...
Actually, it's not worth it, I feel.
Yeah, it's not worth it.
To try and...
Grab stuff.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, it's this way.
Yeah, definitely not worth it.
I'll just kill them now.
Just get rid of that one guy.
Fuck that one slime in particular!
Fuck that guy!
His life don't matter!
Now, fuck you, too!
That's right!
I said it!
Get over here!
I'm charging my sword!
Boom!
Oh shit, I'm fucking getting cocky now.
I always randomly get cocky.
Get over here.
Get closer.
That's right!
Where's the other...
Oh, it's Furnace over here.
Okay, I'm trying to figure out where the other...
Furnace is.
Okay.
It's not worth it, though.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's even worth it to kill these enemies.
Jesus.
Boom!
Cause, like, I'm getting, like, plus one, plus two.
So little.
So little heal...
Like, so little upgrade points.
Yeah, they don't give a lot of soul.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
I killed him before he used his attack.
Like, I don't know.
They give, like, so little, so...
I'll just kill them because they're, like, in the way.
I guess.
Okay.
Be gone!
And then...
Fire!
Oh my god.
Combo.
Oh!
I think if I had the range upgrade, I would've one-shot all of them.
For sure.
A chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki.
It's...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'll get him out first.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank...
Oh, shit.
No!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, give me a sec.
Seed.
Okay.
Drive by.
Okay, there we go.
I did it.
I got the drive by.
There we go.
Medi!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's right here.
Hey, Doki.
I didn't send birthday super chat last year, so can I cash it in now?
You missed out.
No.
It has...
It's like...
It's a 30-day.
You missed a deadline.
You can only cash in birthday super chats if it's within 30 days of your birthday.
Just like taxes.
Star!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
It's my pet rock's birthday today.
Yeah, what's his name?
I kinda wish him a happy birthday.
If I don't know his name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gah!
Oh, there she is.
You little shit.
Crows never do what they're told.
I am trying to save lives here.
Don't you understand?
Death cannot see those who have mastered life force within and earn.
I can fool the grim reaper himself.
You and I have something a little common, crow.
The same employer.
But goodness, we can't have them fighting about everything you've seen.
Don't worry.
I'll put Jemma's...
Wait, I didn't read the last part.
What did she say?
Oh my god, she's a magic user fucking witch.
Never trust magic users.
Pew!
What is she using?
I say as I throw my fire at her.
Never trust magic users.
There we go.
That's not fair.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What the fuck?!
What?!
Oh my god, how did it become Toho?!
What do you mean this isn't Toho?!
Okay.
I guess I never escape Toho.
Okay, nice.
It always was.
I don't know if my fireball does anything when she's in paw form.
You think it does anything?
I can't tell.
I feel like I might get squished.
Oh no, not Toho.
Oh, I can just stand right here.
Oh, it's not that bad.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Thank god, I can just stand right there.
Oh my god, this is so frustrating.
I can't get near enough.
I can't get near enough to use my actual sword.
Because I'm pretty sure that does nothing.
Alright, Toho time.
Stand right here.
Oh shit.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh my god!
She used it against me.
Here we go.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh my god, I'm trying so hard.
Wait, is the paw weak?
I can't tell.
Guys!
Guys, the paw was not weak!
Guys, I'm no longer listening to you guys.
I'm no longer gonna listen.
Aw, damn it.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh my god, no way!
Oh, I'm fucking it up.
I'm fucking it up, guys.
I'm fucking it up right now.
Oh no.
Ping, guys!
It was ping!
Oh, so when she's doing Toho...
When she's doing Toho, it's a weak point, right?
Is that what you mean?
Guys, I hope you're not fucking with me because I'm hitting the pot!
Oh
my god, okay.
Oh, I missed two.
Oh no.
Oh god.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh!
Ah!
I didn't see!
What hit me?
Ah!
I didn't see!
What hit me?
Oh my god.
The reason why I don't get closer is because I can't.
She's too fast.
She's actually too fast to get close.
Oh.
Okay, that doesn't do anything.
I'll just stand here because it's safe.
This grandma's too fast.
I'm fucking it up!
I got too... Oh my god.
Okay.
I got too close.
I got too greedy.
I got way too greedy there.
Okay.
This grandma's way too fast.
Can I damage her when she's in this form?
No, right?
Yeah?
I can?
No?
Guys.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Okay, that's good to know.
Jesus Christ.
Ngh!
Jesus.
Okay, I just gotta fucking run around.
I can't be cocky here.
Okay.
Yeah, I greeded that.
Oh!
Toho.
Toho by standing still.
Just like how I know my Toho.
Okay.
Okay, I can be greedy for these.
Oh!
If she does these, I have to actually just run around.
I didn't realize there was a third one!
Call me.
Oh!
Name five Toho characters.
So there's Toho.
And then there's...
Fuck!
I'm...
You guys...
God damn it!
I blame you guys.
I...
You guys distracted me.
You guys actually distracted me.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
My god.
I think I'm dead.
I can't...
God damn it.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
What?!
I was through the hole!
What was the
hitbox?!
Oh my god.
That hitbox was crazy.
I was actually through the hole.
You don't understand.
I was through the hole.
I swear it looked like I was through.
There's no way!
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
No fucking way.
I'm so mad.
No way.
No, I did not get hit.
I refuse to believe that.
I did not get hit there.
There was no way I got hit there.
Can I actually smack it?
No, I don't believe you guys.
You guys like...
You guys have given me so much misinformation.
I don't believe anymore.
Okay.
Alright.
Got me, huh?
Okay, Toho time.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Oh, whoa!
God damn it.
Okay,
where is he?
Is he gonna appear?
Okay, I'm focusing up.
Oh, there you go.
Two hits.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh my god, you stupid granny.
You stupid fucking granny.
Oh fuck, I'm sorry.
I swear to god.
Okay, I'm gonna try and hit it once and then see if you're lying to me.
Oh my god!
I did it.
Okay.
Guys!
It's very hard to believe you guys sometimes, okay?
This whole time.
I can't believe it.
I never needed that Toho.
Whoa.
My god, why is there a crow there?
We gather here today to mourn the passing of a woman known by many names.
The Witch of Urns.
The Ceramic Sorceress.
The Earthworm Enchantress.
The Crockery Crone.
And of course, Grandma.
Driven by maternal instincts and consumed by endeavors that with death...
She filled her life with passion for magic, renamation potions, and pots.
Her journey is concluded and she is now at peace.
Bow your head in remembrance.
Pay your last respects.
Wait, but you're still a pothead.
Her time in this world is over.
How are we gonna fix him now?
We killed the one...
What if I just...
Let's bow our heads in remembrance.
I'm like...
I suppose I'll never... Yeah.
Yeah, we killed her before she could fix you.
Still, I hope she finds peace beyond life.
She'll finally be reunited with Grandpa.
Split slip of the tongue.
I quite literally have pots on the brain.
Seriously, though.
Rest in peace, Gran.
Can I kill you now?
No.
She died as she lived with a pot on her head.
Okay.
I did it.
Yippee.
I wonder if there's... I wonder if they'll still be around.
I bet the enemies will still be around.
Victor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My birthday was a few days ago.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can, Victor.
Happy birthday to you.
Wait, where am I?
Happy... Whoa!
Happy birthday, dear Victor.
Oh, it's still Grim Reaper!
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Caw.
The Lord of Doors.
Well, a crow.
Hello there.
And how exactly did you get in here?
What's the point in having command over all the doors in this world...
when servants never remember to lock them?
Oh my god, it's him!
The King of Doors!
Sorry, the Lord of Doors.
So why are you here?
I haven't actually met a crow in many, many years.
You still have those... beaks.
Nice.
I sense a vast amount of soul energy about you, little crow.
Strange, it feels oddly familiar to me.
So is that why you're here?
You've come seeking a reward?
Yay!
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
Very good job there.
That's me!
I get a gold star!
Yay!
Guys, I need compliments, okay?
Now be a good little bird...
and turn him into your vault.
There's no need to bring souls directly to me.
I have more important matters to attend to.
Ciao!
Oh my god, and he's Italian?
Woah!
You suck.
Accenture, thank you for the superchat, thank you.
Miller, thank you for the superchat, thank you.
Hello Doki, my birthday was on the first, but you were playing the Vtuber Rivals, so I didn't say anything then.
Can I still get a happy birthday?
Of course!
You claimed it within 30 days, so you got the pass.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Miller, happy birthday to you.
What are you doing here?
Did you find your assignment yet?
Wait, you have a giant soul.
But it's the wrong one?
I can't process that.
How did you manage that?
Nevermind.
Get back there and find your assignments.
Wait, but they already took my giant soul.
I can't do anything.
Alright, I'm gonna save up for strength, guys.
Or I could, actually I'm gonna grab range.
Increase the damage.
And then next up, I'll put it on strength again.
I'm going all in on strength, guys.
Small goose!
Wait, where do I go?
I have a giant soul.
Where'd I go?
Me confused.
Spirits?
To a door.
Guys, I fucking know I have to go...
To a door, you fucking idiot.
Is it the Grove of Spirits?
Where am I?
I don't think it's here.
That's a tutorial.
Where do I go?
I fell down.
The Urn's Witch's Laboratory.
The Manor.
State.
Inner Furnace.
Is it the Cliff Door?
Which one was the Cliff Door?
This one?
That's the Cemetery.
Oh, the Summit Door.
Where the fuck was the Summit Door?
At a Summit Door?
Oh, that's the Cemetery?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll figure this out.
Where was the Summit?
I'll figure...
I'll still figure this out.
Was it up here?
It was up here, right?
Yeah, I don't know now.
It was here.
I don't remember.
Oh, does my Comet Hog go through here now?
No, I'm still too weak.
I'm a weak-ass bird.
Actually, I'm gonna run through these.
These guys don't matter.
Whoa!
Chill, everybody.
Chill.
Oh, wait, what?
I can do that?
All this time?
Nice, my one soul.
Hello, children.
Leave!
It's not my day yet.
It's not my custody day.
Okay, we go up here.
Okay, not this way.
It should be up here.
Whoops.
Wait, what's over here?
Yeah, it's not the weekend yet with Dad.
God, wait.
Okay.
I must have forgot a door or some shit.
That's why I have to fucking walk so far.
I forgot a lock up here?
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
What are you doing?
Huh?
It's Thursday!
I got a soul.
Where's East?
Wait,
where's East?
I don't remember which way is East.
East is right.
Okay, it's the right side.
It's this way.
Okay, it's the one I opened earlier, I think.
It has to be this, right?
I remember West Coast is left because I'm in the West Coast.
So East is always the right.
That's how I remember things.
Oh wait, I can just fall down from there.
It has to be stuff here, right?
Yeah, there's money.
Okay, nice.
There's more money.
Wait...
I haven't been here.
Oh yeah, that's where I have to go.
Okay, I'm gonna check over here first.
Hey mom, I found you on the fucking street.
You were abandoned first.
You're lucky I found it.
I found the seed and I planted it.
You're welcome, children.
Okay, that was a shortcut.
Yeah, I'm like, what fucking mom?
Yeah, okay.
What the fuck?
Is that your purpose in life?
Oh my god, that's his purpose.
That's all he does.
Does he even get paid?
This is his entire life.
It's called a 9 to 5.
You won't ever understand.
You'll never understand, Turkey.
Oh, I can definitely not go there.
Oh wait, this is like a tree level.
So that means that...
Which lever?
Oh, that's a lever.
Couldn't tell.
Okay, big door.
Oh?
Key!
Oh my god, wait.
Wouldn't my fire be like really strong on him?
What the fuck are you gonna do?
You're stationary.
Alright.
Yeah, what the fuck are you gonna do?
You can't even move.
Stupid.
I'll cut you too.
Oh shit.
Hello.
I'm strong!
Watch this!
Sorry, this is the first time that happened.
Don't worry, the second time I'll swear I can totally do it.
Look at that.
See, this is how I found you guys.
You were already abandoned.
But I picked you up.
Look at that.
You're welcome.
Alright, we go this way.
Okay, you're not that strong.
Get over here.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, okay.
Now I know.
Now I know they can do that.
What's this?
Oh, it's a bomb.
Oh, I can like use it.
Oh, wait, that's so cool.
Hey, I like that.
That's a cool ability.
Okay, that's sad.
They're like, um...
They're like that piranha plant in Mario.
You know what?
Just cause I hate you.
There you go.
For no reason too.
Oh, wait!
I am so fucking smart!
Oh my god.
I was like, that shit looks strong as hell.
I knew it.
Alright, time to plant my seed.
Okay.
Oh, I can interrupt it too.
That's good.
That's good to know.
Okay.
Whoa!
Okay, I i-framed that.
I feel like the i-frame is so inconsistent though.
I don't know.
Oh, it rears fire too.
The i-frame?
I don't know.
Or like, it's like super...
It's like super tight or something.
Like, the timing for it is like incredibly tight.
That's like hard to time.
Not just you.
Or it could just be me.
I don't know.
I can...
Get it to hit here.
Aww.
I wonder if I can get it to hit that bridge.
No, I can't.
But what would this hit?
I guess like...
What?!
Okay.
I don't know if I got hit or not.
There's just so many plants.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
What?
I don't think I can move fast enough though.
Yeah.
I don't think I can move fast enough for that.
Fuck!
Okay.
I sorta walked into it.
Think?
I'm thinking.
I'm just gonna...
I have to eat.
Um...
What?
Oh!
I'm so smart.
I didn't look at chat.
That's right.
I figured it out by myself.
Uh-huh.
You have no proof.
My head was facing that way.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Where's your proof?
I'm just very smart.
How do I get that?
I think I need a special ability.
What the fuck?
It's a random insect.
Try to fucking kill me.
I like these mechanics though.
Is it?
Oh, is this a town?
Ooh, that's rough, buddy.
Hello, feathery person.
I'm hard of hearing, so you will have to speak up.
Hey there!
You look like a fellow traveler.
What brings you here?
Did you come to learn the music of the forest children as well?
What a shame it is that the forest elder lost her horn.
I hope she finds it soon so I can hear her beautiful melodies.
Hey, where is she?
Is she hot?
Who's the forest elder?
Is she cute?
Oh, am I gonna find more seeds?
Oh, no seeds.
Oh shit!
Okay.
This is a little scary though.
Okay, I gotta get rid of him.
Okay.
Oh wait, leather!
Shortcut!
More shortcuts!
That I'm gonna forget about.
Because there's too many shortcuts.
There's too many shortcuts, guys.
There's way too many shortcuts.
Oh my god.
There's so much to this map.
Oh my god!
Look, I picked up a seed though.
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna backtrack.
Because I didn't explore more of the backside.
Oh wait!
Wait, what the fuck?
You're following me.
Big fan.
Lots of shortcuts that I'm gonna forget about.
Is this the...
Oh shit, I forgot to talk to the what?
The most important person.
But we converse in songs, sadly.
I have lost my magic horn.
I left it in the old camp to the north.
Alas, we were driven from there by the Frog King's henchmen.
If you return to me, I'm sure we can help you on your journey.
Okay, we gotta find a magic horn for the big lady.
Big strong lady.
Hey, was there anything over here that I missed?
No, I didn't go up here though.
There's a ladder up here.
I need to steal some stuff from them.
Yoink!
Another cut city.
Right now.
Giant woman.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I thought I accidentally...
I was gonna say I accidentally clipped into it.
No.
Wait, I can't do anything there.
Okay, I'll just pull this lever.
Okay.
That's for another area.
I'll go this way then.
Oh my god, they're all following me.
You little freaks.
Don't do this.
That's fucking...
Oh, you're crying now?
That's all?
Shit!
Okay, that may or may not have been karma, guys.
I may or may not have just got karma there.
Stupid kids.
Get rid of these guys.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
That's right, what you gonna do?
Nothing!
Okay, bring me up top.
I want uppies now.
Give me uppies!
Oh, shit.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
Oh, yeah, what you gonna do?
You're stationary.
Oh, okay, I can hit that too.
Okay.
Now that I know, I can basically hit...
Okay, I can basically hit every projectile.
I can reflect all projectiles.
Now I know that.
It took me a while.
It only took me three hours to figure that out.
Guys.
Just three hours.
No big deal.
Where do I go?
Oh, this way.
Right?
No?
Where did it lock me up?
Can I go left?
I just want to be sure.
Okay, I go left.
Alright.
Oh, I have one shot now.
Nice, I'm strong.
I'm so fucking strong.
Alright.
Off we go.
Oh, shortcut!
Yay, shortcut!
Anything here?
There's so much...
So many pathways!
Where do I go?
Okay, guys.
Do I...
Okay, there's like...
There's like something here.
I don't know if I go through here.
Like...
Is it worth going through this tunnel?
Oh, well, too late.
It was not worth going through that tunnel.
Well...
Yes, it wasn't worth it.
What shortcut did I unlock?
What the fuck was the shortcut that I unlocked just then?
Is it this shortcut?
Which shortcut did I unlock?
Which one?
Oh, man!
Oh, did I miss?
Oh, my God.
The fireball didn't hit.
I was like, wait.
I thought I was supposed to unlock it.
You little fucking shithead.
Fucking cry.
Okay.
Alright, let's do this again.
Alright, uppies.
Uppies!
Okay, and then we go...
This way.
And then...
And I'm just gonna wait here and...
Do this.
There we go.
Now we unlock the sh- I was like wondering.
I was like, that had to be the shortcut I just unlocked.
I was so confused.
Fucking...
Get over here.
Oh, my God, you little shit.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Wait!
Pray time!
Wait.
Crocod?
Crocod, are you okay?
Hello?
Crocod no respond.
Crocod doesn't wanna respond to me.
I don't think Crocod's alive, guys.
Okay, three hits.
That's good.
Where go?
Go where?
I'm confused.
Oh, here we go.
Get over here.
Nice.
Okay, three hits.
And a nice shortcut.
Shortcut.
Yay!
Custody!
I'm Crocod now, you're right.
Wait, there's another shortcut.
I don't see these places.
So many shortcuts.
Oh, this way.
I think there has to be like a teleportation spell.
Because there's so much water around here.
But it's like, what do I do with all that water?
Oh, my God, where do I go?
I don't know.
When I have too many options, I get so overwhelmed.
Too many options.
Where go?
Why is there so many of these plants?
Oh.
Guys, I figured out why.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Don't have to do anything at all.
Okay, now I know why.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My birthday was two days ago.
Can I get a happy birthday card?
Of course you can.
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
I didn't even see that rock was breakable.
A happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Small Goose.
Gah!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, now I should be able to break that.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not Togi rubbing the salt on the wound.
What?
Does it hit all the way there?
Oh, it does!
Nice.
It was worth it.
Gah!
Okay.
Wait, is there anything else?
What the fuck?
Anything here?
Where am I?
Oh, there's another plant.
Wait.
Okay, there's a shortcut.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Everything's blurring together, guys.
Consume.
Everything's blurring together.
I don't remember where is what.
Oh, there's the horn!
I got the horn!
Mata would be pleased.
Nice.
Oh, so that's where you're like...
That's what happened.
Where do I go?
I wanna go here.
Where do I go now?
Wait, what?
I can't open this.
Huh?
I don't go fast enough.
I'm not fast enough for that.
Confused.
Alright, everything's a shortcut if you think about it.
There we go.
Yeah, but how do I do this?
This one.
Oh, I am fast enough!
I'm gaming.
I am fast enough.
That's right.
I don't need to invest in speed.
I'll always be fast enough.
Okay, swing.
Swing.
Wait, why is that not anything?
Anything for this?
No?
Okay.
But where do I go now?
Where do I go now?
Pro-key confused.
Do I go home?
I guess I go home, right?
But where is home?
Mother.
Back to mother.
You're right.
Stupid babies.
Oh my god.
There's a lever here that I can't open.
What's the point?
What the fuck is the point?
Okay.
Shortcut.
Oh, I did open a shortcut!
Oh!
Hello, I found you.
Your horn.
My horn!
Thank you, feathery friend.
Sing for me, mother.
Sing for me!
Thank
you, mother.
Yay!
Wait, what happened?
I closed my eyes.
Wait, what opened?
I actually closed my eyes.
I don't know.
Wait,
guys.
I'm actually serious.
I closed my eyes.
The door blocked by the vines?
The fuck is that?
Wait, where is that?
I remember no dungeon.
Wait.
Oh, guys.
Guys, I'm confused.
I actually don't know.
What is that?
No elk.
Guys, I actually don't know.
I closed my eyes.
I don't know where...
I don't know where to go.
Oh, the door to the overworld?
Are there any doors here?
Oh my god, where am I?
Okay.
Oh, pray time.
I don't know how I got here.
Oh god, please.
Oh!
I have two shards.
Two more.
Oh wait, that's the wrong one.
Wait, I need the heal one.
Are you fucking serious?
Where am I?
Oh no, I don't know where I am.
Where am I at?
Grokey's so confused.
Grokey confused.
Grokey wants to find out where she is.
Where am I?
Oh my god, I'm going downstairs.
Oh, is it this?
Oh, I found it!
I did it!
On accident.
Let's go.
Grokey's smart.
Hello.
Oh, a little birdie.
Come cage, save me.
Big frog lock Grunt here.
Grunt clever too much.
Oh my god, he speaks my language.
Grunt have good ideas and big frog no like.
Grunt know what wear.
Big frog mask.
Big frog know except Grunt is individual.
Oh my god, he's just like me for real for real.
Wait, what do I do?
Wait, what?
Oh, I burn this.
I forgot that's like cobwebs.
They look like, I don't know why.
In my head, it doesn't seem like cobwebs.
So I keep forgetting I can...
I keep forgetting that I can just like...
Open that up.
With fire.
The fuck is that?
Is that big frog?
What?
Oi, reaper.
What are you doing here?
Why, my Grunt said there are some shady crows causing trouble in the ruins.
I'll come see for myself.
You're here for my soul?
Then tough luck.
I earn my power fair and square.
I'm just thriving in the system your lords created.
That's right.
I don't care.
I hunger for souls.
Oh, it's another one of those guys.
What you doing in my swamp?
Oh my god, I hate these children.
They're so annoying.
There we go, get over here.
That's right, you think crying is gonna fucking...
Wait, I can't do anything here.
Crying is not gonna save you.
Same with you.
Oh, so it doesn't matter.
Oh wait, no, it's here.
Okay, I didn't see that.
That's so tiny.
Time.
Okay.
Huh?
Confused.
What?
Okay, now I don't have any powers left.
Huh?
Cookie confused.
Oh, there's another one.
Okay, maybe this one is actually gonna work.
Oh, okay.
I was supposed to go here.
Plant my seed.
Kill this guy first.
Oh shit.
Alright, nice.
I was supposed to go here.
That's so dumb.
How the fuck was I supposed to know I was supposed to go here?
Now I need to burn that.
Yay!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, don't worry.
I got the strat.
I hit this, and then everything dies.
Okay, I missed.
But like, I hit this...
And then everything...
Ow.
Okay, I'm not gonna be fancy.
I just kill.
Okay, but everything dies.
Okay, nevermind.
Guys, I'm gonna stop doing that now.
I've learned my lesson.
If it happens, it happens, you know?
If it happens, it happens.
Oh my god, it's those little shitheads.
Get over here.
Crying onion children.
There we go.
Yay!
Alright, crow man.
Crow man.
Locked in a grimy dungeon.
Not the way I wanted to go.
Goodbye.
Okay, four.
I have to save four crows?
Why do all these crows keep dying?
Is the frog gonna talk to me?
Or is he mad?
Those children.
They know it's not their day.
Look at that.
See?
Those kids know it's not their day.
Where else do I go?
I'm so confused.
Where go?
Where do I go?
Oh, here.
Oh shit.
Don't worry, I'm fast enough.
See?
Look at that.
I knew I was fast enough.
Oh wait, I just make it.
I have to get both of them.
There we go.
Shion!
Come with me.
Oh, there we go.
I am speed.
I don't need no speed upgrade.
I'm fast as fuck.
Woah!
Woah, calm down!
Calm down!
Unlock.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I now?
Where did I come from?
This is a big ass dungeon.
I like how this roll is actually faster.
I think?
Or is it placebo?
Actually, I don't know now.
Hahaha!
Actually, maybe it's not.
Maybe it's the same speed.
Now that I look at it...
Guys, I don't think it's faster.
I can't tell actually.
Oh, there's another dead crow.
No!
Oh, fucking hell!
What the fuck is that?
There's another boss?
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god!
He just hits me!
Bro!
He just hammers me!
What do I do?
Oh my god!
Now there's another one!
Guys, I don't...
Guys, it ain't looking so good.
Guys, it ain't looking so good for Doki right now.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I'm like 1 HP.
Oh, it ain't looking so good for Doki!
Oh!
I thought he got me.
Okay.
I got you!
Assault, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey,
don't speak of the lord like that!
He is lord!
For a reason!
Okay.
Off we go!
This game is so addicting.
I wanna stop.
I have another long stream tomorrow.
Planting a seed.
Whoa!
Don't mind me.
Just out for a swim.
Can you join me, Reaper?
No?
Probably a wise decision.
If I'm being honest...
I was gonna try and drown you.
See, I'm being honest.
Surely that counts for something.
What do you say?
Truce?
That's right.
No truce.
Fight against water.
Surely that's the way.
Oh, this...
I don't know how I'm gonna do that one.
That's way too fast.
Right?
Yeah, I can't get a TP.
I can't make it to the other side.
I was thinking like, yeah, that's way too fast.
Wait, no, I have a key.
I don't have a key.
Maybe I'm gonna go for the other door first.
Actually.
Just cause I...
Oh no.
I think I should go the other door first.
Yeah.
Just cause there is an entrance here.
What's over here?
Swing!
Oh wait, no, there is something.
What's over here?
Oh, another lever.
Okay.
I hate...
I think the furnace level is the most annoying.
That's for sure.
For now.
The gloops.
I hated the gloops and that stupid plague doctor boss.
Fuck that guy.
Oh, you just wait.
Oh no.
What do you mean by that?
For now.
Oh no.
Anything here?
There's like all these TP areas, but I can't use it.
Hey, huh?
I guess it has to be the TP, right?
Is that a threat?
What's this?
Oh, this is not a shortcut.
I should not go up there.
Oh!
That's how I get it.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice haul.
Okay.
Yeah, I should not drop down.
I don't want to walk all the way here again.
Okay.
What do you have here?
More ladders?
Oh my god.
That's what I've always wanted.
More ladders.
Shortcut.
Oh my god.
A dream come true.
What's here?
Wait, what is here?
Where the fuck- Oh!
I'm so smart.
And I was like, what's here?
I did it.
You equip it from the- Oh my god, giant hammer.
1.2, dat.
Wow.
How do I do this?
Wait.
No.
Oh my god.
Giant hammer.
Okay.
What do I do with giant hammer then?
Wait, can I throw it?
No, I can't.
Wait, can I bash it?
No, I can't even break- What the fuck's a point?
Okay.
What do I do with this giant hammer?
It looks cool.
But where
- Oh, it's here.
That's what has to let me TP, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's what makes me TP.
But like, I don't know- I need to figure out how to get there.
Is this- Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay, nevermind.
It's this!
This thing here!
It's right here!
Where'd it go?
Yeah, but I can't- I'm not fast enough for this one.
This one, I'm not fast enough.
No.
I'm not fast enough.
I'm too slow.
I'm too slow, girl.
Be slow.
Where'd it go?
I don't know where to go, guys.
But I don't want all the enemies to respawn just yet.
Where'd it go?
Where do I go?
Where?
I can't!
I can't light those fires, guys!
You wanna know why?
Because I need TP right there.
I can't light this one.
The one down here.
I can't light the one down here.
Oh, I can fall down.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I did it.
I didn't see it.
What's everyone's like out there?
It's a mess.
A wasteland.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew those hippies were in the way.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
It sure smells bad down there.
Okay, let's see how this goes.
Oh my god!
Guys, it's not going so well.
Guys, it might not be go-
Alright, I'm calling that there.
That's a good time to call it.
Do I autosave?
It does, right?
Alright.
Crow with big hammer was not it.
Guys, that's fun though.
I think I'm like- I should be like close to finishing, right?
It says like, this game is like 8 hours long.
So like, I'm pretty sure.
Right?
But, I had fun.
I think this game is- Yeah, I'll finish in part 2.
But I do have another livestream tomorrow.
So I don't want to do too many livestreams in a row.
Just cause like, my voice is still hitting.
But I had a lot of fun.
Oh my god, I can upgrade!
Strength.
If all else fails, I'm gonna be maxed out.
Big strong bird man coming through.
That's right.
Big strong bird.
Big strong crow coming in.
That's fucking right.
I'm the strength chat.
No defense.
Get juiced up.
That's right, you see that?
Bam!
That's right, croaky smash!
Haha!
That's fun!
I really enjoyed this game.
I think like, if I didn't have a livestream tomorrow, I definitely would've streamed a lot, lot longer for sure.
But, I hope you guys enjoyed watching today.
Watching DevStore.
If you guys enjoyed croaky, like I said, just gonna do a little chill here.
But, yeah!
If you enjoyed croaky, I have croaky plushies, as well as two other official plushies out right now!
It's really helpful!
If you wanna support me, my stream, and potential more merch collaborations in the future, support by buying a croaky plush!
Buy one now!
Yippee!
Alright, chill done.
I'm finished chilling.
Hey guys, that was really fun!
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
It's a little different from what I usually play, but I like it.
I like this game a lot so far.
Um, I like...
I just... I don't know.
I really enjoyed the... I enjoyed the combat for sure, until they start spamming like 800 enemies on me.
Then I don't enjoy the combat anymore.
But like, other than that, it's been really fun so far.
And...
Uh, and...
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'm gonna try and finish part two.
For part two, I'm just gonna try and do like uh, I finish the game.
I don't wanna make it a multi-series.
I'm pretty sure we're almost done.
Like, it's like what, two more bosses?
And then like, big boss time, maybe?
This is...
I checked, it said it was an eight hour game.
It was like a six to eight hour game, so...
It won't be that bad, right guys?
Haha.
Hey guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Woah!
Shit, you don't see me cause I actually closed it.
Um...
Hahaha!
Secret ending!
So, I didn't show this because I wanna ask permission if I could show it because they sent it to me on DMs.
So I wasn't sure if I was able to show it to you guys.
Um, because like, I was like, Oh, did you send it to me DMs?
I don't know if it was just like, to show it to me or something.
So I didn't wanna like, cause any trouble.
But they were like, no, no, you can show it if you want to.
I was like, yippee!
Okay, let me get myself on screen real quick.
I closed I reverted out of croquis, so I got turned back into croquis real quick.
Um, secret ending, secret ending, give me a sec, I'm trying to find this real quick.
Okay, secret ending, secret, I need to get croquis back on before I show what the secret ending is.
Give me a sec guys.
Croquis.
I need to turn back into croquis before, uh, before I can show you guys what it is.
Okay, um, okay, okay, I have to face this way.
Alright, okay, croquis back.
I think?
Is croquis back?
No, croquis not back.
The fuck?
Oh, croquis back.
Oh, croquis tiny.
Give me a sec.
Okay, okay.
Um, secret ending, secret ending, but, uh, uh, Paco Paco-sensei DM'd this to me.
Oh wait, no, not this.
Buy my merch.
But Paco-sensei DM'd this to me and was like, I really love watching you and I always get energy from you and um, and I love that he drew stars for me.
I I I I
I love I love that he drew this is like the big illustration of, um, but yeah, I just wasn't sure if I was allowed to show it.
I thought it was just like for memes only, but then I asked and he's like, yeah, no, you can show it, whatever you want.
I was like, thank you, oh my god, thank you for drawing me.
I really appreciate it.
Uh, uh, uh,
he drew stars he was like, hilarious.
I just got approval.
I just got permission from him that I could show it.
So yeah, secret ending.
Okay, buh-bye for real now.
Buh-bye.